now going live
okay
now is go time hello hello hello
everybody access the stream welcome to
the greg birthday live healthy stream we
got here please contribute he's broke we
need
thousands of likes on this
we need to get to at least five thousand
likes
when we're live tell us you can hear us
greg spent all his money getting himself
hooked up to that interview with the
director we can hear you says prin
prince600 hey we're live what's up
people
annual birthday live stream and i got
i got my brother with me today let's
shout out everyone in the chat [ __ ]
casey benton i hope it's only jaby coway
followers who are here
how many strings greg had to pull to get
me
sema
faith gail oh thank you for all the
happy birthdays
ian cuevas
yes jaby and greg i need more of this
um let's see phillip daniel jumbo
squeeze casey hey
uh huey king bateman how's it going
thank you guys so much this means a lot
just gonna be an open q a today uh i
think on monday which will be labor day
giving enough people time to watch
chongqi uh we'll probably do a live
stream spoiler talk discussing shanghai
uh that's how you pronounce it by the
way i feel like a lot of people are
still saying i still say
shame on you my asian brother you should
be saying
sometimes sometimes i say
and then people look at me funny yeah
it's a little um that's a little
controversial
thank you guys so much thank you guys so
much but yeah uh just gonna be an open q
a today they call me a race car
only serious questions
this is gonna be fun uh we're all
drinking some form of energy drinks
right now yes that's what we're doing
today i'm high off of greg's energy move
the chat to here
johnson see it yeah
we're all looking to the right i'm not
like texting in the middle of this by
the way i'm just trying to promote this
thing because greg's only got like 12
people watching right now thank you
you're so nice thank you alex no he's
got you got 210 people if we were
talking about spider-man we'd have two
thousand people
this is spider-man
trailer talk when it's just about greg
we should just put spider-man no way
home in the title yes
yes
uh thank you i know some people have
contributed to the super chats and that
that means a lot we'll get to those in
just one minute well you know if you
contribute a super chat greg will
consider you when he blows out his
candles someone wants you to say
something i assume is naughty in in in
hindi
andy
is that was that the word did you say it
did you is that how you say it i don't
know what the hell you're saying yeah i
don't know what that means so we just
insulted so many people
guys look you guys
i appreciate all the happy birthdays
that means more than you know and thank
you for all the support over the years
or the week or the months or even if you
just subscribed today
uh but yeah you know um
you guys drive this live stream at the
end of the day you know as much as it's
my birthday i just want to make sure you
guys are the ones who are driving this i
want to make sure my brother is as
engaged as he is right now i'm trying to
set up the advertisement for this gosh
darn stream the advertisement oh okay
yeah so uh jaby kawaii is is my older
brother a lot of people don't realize
that they think he's younger than me
which makes me feel good because it
shows just how much more mature i come
across versus him he is like
the uh luke wilson to my owen oh yeah he
is like uh my jake paul to my logan
mm-hmm he is like damn twin brother of
vin diesel oh yeah to my vin diesel
you know you're not making me feel good
hamilton
you're making me [ __ ]
that is what we have going on you're
trying to pump me up it's not working
i'm trying to pump you up right now i'm
trying to pump you up
he has a great channel jaby coy does
have a great channel yeah
he's uh he's a little bit more uh
analytical than me i i'd say i'm more
like hippy emotional he's more like
that's how i would describe it
i just like to keep my room clean what's
wrong with that we don't keep the room
clean that's right he's older he's older
man that's right
my god would you look now you're just
chilling on instagram right now we got
it
i'm trying to pump it up
martin s is a fan of the jabby koe
glasses yes vin diesel does have a twin
jaby used to beat me up hard when i was
uh when i was a little kid yeah it was
wrong
i did yeah yeah you know one time he
upset me so what i did was i put gel
on the inside of his blanket so that way
when he would lay down he would be
covered in gel i don't remember that and
then he came out and then had a slab of
gel in his hat and smacked me across bed
and i was like i deserve that
that was well deserved disney thank you
guys for all the happy birthday wishes
by the way love to the netherlands and
also uh amardeep rahul thought you were
related to mike shinoda jaby coast uh
yeah totally yes both greg and i are
related to mike schneider yes both the
same ethnicities
how how how long are you gonna be on
this instagram app i'm literally
advertising your stuff what is taking
you so long you do you think too much
about it you need to be more than the
time you're done advertising the stream
will be done i'm actually in my 30s guys
i'm in my 30s
35 years old today he is 48 years old
here we go john is 24. i am done you
guys would be very surprised i was held
back a lot yeah
it's okay okay i'm present i like that
uh
you're using the comic book i gave you
to prop up the monitor i mainly do that
with any gifts from my siblings
greg touted himself as a big big fan of
the walking dead i'm like here you go i
went out and got this comic for you it's
the first issue
the super compendium first compendium
and greg's like oh i love it i'll read
it every day every day and and here it
is i haven't been here in a while it's
propping up the monitor i i don't uh
read comics guys i only watch
new rockstars videos and i and then i uh
i i will go to wikipedia a lot of the
time oh yeah i just go what can i quote
here in a trailer reaction to make it
sound like i know what i'm talking about
plain and simple that's honestly not
much that's so honest it's not a lot of
honesty on youtube i know and now you
get honesty today that's how you get on
my breath my gift to you are we going to
talk about spiderman
i mean only spiderman i appreciate all
the birthday comments and all the happy
birthdays
but you know i like we need some
questions in here just throw some
questions first question that comes up
in the chat i'll get we'll get to the
super chats in a second we we got to
earn our weight yeah we got a scale oh
i've never done a live stream what's
going on a lot of people just hop to the
super chat i know we do look alike
we will do the shanxi uh spoiler review
on uh on monday that is we'll do a live
stream one
for the 100 people who show up for that
shanxi one
there's 500 people here right now aria
can we block the number of people who
are here and also for those why why why
do you want to block that because it
distracts me and i get caught up in
numbers and i just like to be invested i
was in the chat i love it it lets me
know how anxious i should be
yeah you see that's the big difference
between you and yeah i like the anxiety
i get i just want to tend to the people
who are here in the chat right now and
those who tend to show up instead of
going why aren't there more people here
because my mind always goes there no
matter how many people are here
even if we like break 4 000 i'm like
why is it not 4 500 if campia was doing
the same livestream there'd be more
okay okay okay jenna has a question she
wants to know our thoughts on tom and
zendaya i think it's great that tom
holland and zendaya are together guys if
you could go i want to get this 1 000
likes tom holland and dare dating yeah
you're you're you're joking right now
it's wrong you got to do spiderman
that's what you got to do as a
spider-man actor is date your mary jane
that's right oh does that happen every
single time the only way you know
they're taking it seriously i believe
toby maguire and uh kirsten dunst went
on a few dates
but that's right and andy oh did you
know that uh the person who did the
upside-down kiss wasn't always tobey
maguire no i did not yeah there was a
stunt guy in it because because
whoever did it i just learned about this
the other day from a stunt coordinator
apparently toby mcguire felt like he was
getting waterboarded because all that
rain was coming down on him while he's
upside down and he's like you got one of
these and so i don't actually know if
tobin maguire actually did the kiss no
no way because like it was some stunt
guy who was doing it also dang
yeah stunt kiss stunt kiss for sure
that's a true story we interviewed
yesterday um
i thought it was gonna be like 10
minutes it turned into 45 minutes we
interviewed have you guys heard of the
channel marshall club no um well it's a
great show you would love it uh i would
yeah you would like i think you would
love it okay
and andy lee who plays the death dealer
in shanghai he's the guy in the trailers
with like the interesting looking mask
uh
he is uh he he has started off on
youtube eventually got asked by the stun
brad allen brad allen he specifically
recruited him sought him out and then he
got brought into shanghi and then we did
an interview with him for 40 minutes and
we've been a big fan of his channel for
such a long time you interviewed andy
lee yeah oh wow
that guy came into like that but you
haven't heard of marshall club no i
haven't i haven't oh no no i have
actually i i didn't know what you were
talking about are you talking on
instagram no it's all about history okay
he's got he's got a thing on instagram
called marshall club or something like
that
so i'm aware of that the promotion
okay i didn't know that i'm aware of
that instagram account i watched his
stuff i just discovered who he was and i
was like oh my god this guy like
uh what do you call ascended the ranks
super super fast because he was like
making stuff on youtube just a few years
ago yeah and now he's like in the marvel
film which is nuts he's super talented
i'm pretty sure i just said that and you
just said it longer i wasn't paying
attention yeah i wasn't thinking i do
know who this person is go to bed mr
bravo i was paying attention to the
super chats that you haven't addressed
yet mr bravo's all right our dreams guys
if uh if you guys can avoid shang chi
spoilers we're not going to talk any
shanxi spoilers and john is going to
have his butt in here ready to hide any
user who's spoiling that movie
because uh yeah there's a lot of people
who are already like posting
images from the post post-credits scene
on on their thumbnails like last night
not just images like they're talking
about full-on they're just talking about
it like explaining it if they're talking
about it full-on i get it but when
you're showing like the thumbnail
moments i'm like maybe don't do it on
the thursday
before people have seen it yeah you
should maybe
i could understand even saturday like a
thursday just so you all know batman
gets away and he has dinner or lunch
with uh cat woman that's true they cgi'd
out see me louise
mustache that movie
um all right guys let's uh we've got
some super chats and and some people
have contributed already let's like john
can you pull them up
did you notice wong had a five o'clock
shadow in what if episode four he did
yeah he did he doesn't have a five
o'clock shadow in real life well he's a
variant anything can happen
i said that too
i'm like this doesn't make any sense no
it's very inaccurate i'm a virgo i
should be more analytical i'm pretty
analytical in real life as a half asian
i'm offended at the five o'clock shadow
that he had
why i could get at five o'clock can't
you get a five o'clock shadow this is my
[ __ ] box right now you've got what
constitution
has a beard right now avengers zen game
is my favorite uh uh mcu film hannah
that's the worst of the films oh no it's
not i just want to see the viewership
drop
[Laughter]
like no god all righty i'm so i know i'm
excited to have that debate again no
shang chi spoilers no
doesn't say anything in that one
my favorite mcu film is avengers end
game my favorite villain would be tony
liang from uh
shanghai i would say that tony long is
how you pronounce it actually what's
funny is i went on twitter and i was
like all these people pronouncing chung
chi wrong and everything i realized i've
been saying tony long wrong this entire
time and here i am trying to correct
everyone
this is tony lung what were
i'm sure he's fine with it that rogue
i'm sure i'm sure he's not hurting from
those millions of dollars that he's
getting he knows he's all right he's
asian he got paid thousands of dollars
last last song
wolverine does die at the end
there will be no secrets yeah and they
bring wolverine back and they just kill
him off
right then and there one second
he does get to say the f word though uh
let's see here he does oh do we have the
super chats which movie was that where
he says the effort it's days of future
past oh that's right and he's smoking a
cigar you think you'd be more focused
with having your brother here instead of
koi but then
something no because it's sorry koi
locks in and will monologue
like so on topic it's not funny
whereas this is a bit more it's really
good it's intimidating i was on i was on
collider with him and i was like oh god
i better not say anything at all
i got really quiet all right let's go
into this alto vol volte thank you so
much dude happy birthday greg who do you
want a lap dance from oh ryan gosling uh
ryan gosling would be my dream lap dance
i thought you're gonna say jaby kawaii
just to make it awkward it's [ __ ]
disgusting
i don't even know
man fun
hey you just said happy birthday to me
in the live stream thanks jaby
um
oh i see they're live they're my dreams
coming true if we go to their live
stream
it's a double livestream thing if we go
to theirs they're looking at us right
now
oh how funny yeah okay i'll see if i can
pull that up yeah yeah make it happen
get it picture and picture trading a
beaver boat how's it going greg that's
directed to you how is it going the
little pair wants to know i appreciate a
fever but it's going well you know i
kind of overslept a little bit because
um
you didn't i mean you didn't have issues
getting what if up i feel like we were
the only ones who like had to really
fight to get what if up on a wednesday
because i literally had to do seven
edits and i couldn't figure out i was
like talking to as many people as i can
i'm like i'm doing literally all the
things that all my friends are saying
why the hell can i get this that was
super easy i didn't even have to try i
know you didn't even edit it down
so then i only got like two hours of
sleep that day and i feel like i'm still
sort of recovering from from that and so
yeah i'm a little bit a little bit out
of it but it's supposed to go out uh my
fiance is taking me somewhere tonight i
don't know where specifically but she's
going to put a bag over your head and
shove you in there
wake up in the middle of the desert
happy birthday
tell me where the white rabbit is what
are you talking about i don't know why
am i buried up to my neck
philip carney
happy birthday i love your channel
i was thinking of the scene from seven
all of a sudden thank you for that
what's in the box what's in the box it's
something you've always wanted general
rule of thumb guys and we're reading
something for super chat we give them
undivided
riff on the super chat unless we're
ripping it out
love your channel thank you phillip i
really appreciate it carney that's
awesome sophie says i like blind wave
more than both of your channels you
should upvote that thank you for being
here we're going to pin that card blind
wave supported me on patreon for a
little bit blind supports us too and i
don't know why they did that
yeah i was like who are these people
yeah you know that was the way was the
og's yes oh you got to appreciate
[ __ ] who come into your live
stream on your birthday to put you down
yeah real best [ __ ] in the
world that's the best kind of reverse
psychology
yeah
that pumps me up connie's saying connie
my dear
connie has given us so much equipment
did you say connie is going to get fired
from jbl did you say genghis khan yes uh
connie gave us her tag of places
oh my gosh you guys we're talking about
connie
it's on topic totally did you know most
of us are related to genghis khan
all right
seriously that's on topic isn't it
oh it's not true
it's drifting connie gave us
some amazing speakers that we still have
not set up because we're always lagging
on things we have we have a whole
section of boxes right here which is
things we have generous
okay here's here's a here's a topical
question is her last name sang or song
like shang ah
she could tell us connie if you're in
the chat tell us
her last name is is just as it appears
but her first name is kenny okay
what that's not true
we are it's good this live stream we're
never gonna get moving right now no wait
wait i haven't even said the thing i've
been trying to say about connie
all right what about connor we need to
meet up with you connie she's giving us
some incredible things she even wears my
headphones she's giving us three jbl
headphones which you don't wear yeah we
do we wear them in every video i wear
them right here these are the nights
every video we wear them man
and then uh yeah she's she's really
supportive all right let's just move on
yeah thank you connie
i would like some jbl headphones get
yourself some jbl clubs all right let's
move on youtube.com
thank you so much
i would like some jbl we love you jaby's
not let us know your name actually
doesn't smoke weed i don't surprisingly
i feel like it would help him a lot i
smoke low it would change your demeanor
uh kevin norris hey spark smoke shop in
the chat hell yeah
um kevin norris happy birthday do you
think episode of what if is setting up
future doctor strange i firmly believe
we are going to see um supreme that's
his name right supreme strange
supreme strange
up here at some point in live action it
would be really cool if he does appear
in multiverse of madness i think that
would be such a can you imagine seeing
two live-action dr strange and they're
very different personas you know it
wouldn't be
it's like you know in captain america
captain america appears like you got
duel of him in avengers end game but
they're just like from two different uh
timelines like from the past in the
future essentially how great would it be
to see two different doctor strangers
both play by benedict cumberbatch live
action because what i've been wanting
them to do and i think they're doing it
with captain carter um they're br the
way how the mandalorian has been
bringing characters from clone wars into
live action people like ahsoka tano
people like bo katan and then if you
could do that with the what if
portrayals put them into live action i
think that would a just make people more
invested in what if realize the
significance of it probably get more
people to tune into what if even going
back and revisit it the way how it
happened with clone wars like clone wars
saw a surge in views after it was like
appearing in mandalorian and also just
be just awesome like how great would it
be to invent something for animated and
then bring it to live action so i saw
some things that i'm not allowed to talk
about i'll tell you what i saw after the
live stream is over
but great to see you
but you guys aren't allowed to listen
what i will say
what i will say what i will say is that
you should definitely be watching what
if okay it's like if you haven't started
you should definitely be watching it
that's all i can say he's friends with
kevin figgy
for now kevin
kevin
correct way to pronounce it
all right thank you kevin norris
absolutely you guys drive the streams
with your questions you bring in
alexander bem
and i appreciate everyone who's like
super chat to say happy birthday but you
know if you do decide a super chat
please make sure to follow up with a
question everyone who's super chats greg
will wish good sex for you guys in his
birthday wish
yeah everybody deserves that you just
gotta remember make a wish correct you
get one wish i want everyone from my
live stream to have good sex it's a
make-a-wish foundation that's my
follow-up
oh right alexander bem uh every time i
hear it's my birthday i always imagine
the song in the spaceship from
ragnarok good reference right there
alexander thank you so much i always
found alexander to be such a
strong name yeah it's like alexander the
great like it's also a library you know
what's a weak name what
anthony yeah
terrible name
why would you ever name your son that
name right jabby or daughter anthony
there's nothing hard in it even the t is
birthday stream i'd still be roasting
that's the way it would go yeah yeah
yeah no you got to uh alex uh alma
powell alma powell happy born day
thank you for the great content
dude almost
that's really i like that last name
that's a fun last name you got elma
are you saying what are you saying all
right so jaby that's a great way to
introduce yourself what's your name elmo
pow and never forget it i was joking
about the anthony thing that was a dig
at someone i know yeah it's it's not
who's in this stream if your name is
anthony you're not weak you're my live
stream yeah all right all right so who
do we got here uh mr jaby why don't you
read this one song if there's any
spoilers
we're not going to read it
but you know we'll still accept the
super chat we're not going to read it
today loved it you think what they
mentioned in the mid credits scene
undeniably removes the netflix shows
from canon happy birthday without going
into spoilers at all literally no
spoilers um
i don't think so what i don't even know
how that even links with the multiverse
now i don't think anything is removed
from anywhere
freaking all the people from like you
know what sony films before the mcu
existed i'm pretty sure that doesn't
undo anything from netflix but the after
credit scene definitely proves that it
was daredevil who put those papers on
the table in front of me
not his belly man he's got too much
belly now it's not him that's what i
said i was like there's no way it's him
i i mean we could be right we could be
right together apparently tom holland is
in spiderman now at home cedric
pelletier with the uh major scoop there
i don't know he was going to be in it
[Laughter]
i thought all shots of tom holland were
just hiding toby mcguire yeah they're
all it's only tom and it's only over
there theory floating about that oh yeah
definitely there's always going to be
theory especially because we know the
marvel trailers will manipulate except
shang chi they hadn't done that
here's a twist that i really hope for is
that we find out that this tom holland
that we're now following is a different
multiversal tom holland than the uh
homecoming or far from home ones up
until a certain point that's not at all
let's confuse the hell yeah let's
confuse everybody
tins with a big old zed
can't wait for shang chi review with
spoilers absolutely loved it really want
to go watch it again i do too um we're
taking the family
the asian family of the alba's
and the adopted coe aren't a white guy
are gonna go watch uh shang chi again on
sunday i wanted to make sure mama could
watch it yeah so she could because i go
in with have some asian pride and
annoying her she's gonna walk out going
i liked it
you know it's like ironic it was okay
you know what's so ironic is that when i
was younger i was like leaning in hard
to the asian thing and greg was like
you're so asian obsessed jesus and now
greg's the one leading into the asian
thing and i'm like asian what what are
those i was what's an asian
i don't see color that was the way i
talked back then
yesterday i just want to be just like
you when i'm older
anthony i want to have as much asian
pride because you don't want to be just
like you
thank you
hope you enjoy your second viewing
master bird
happy birthday greg this is so crazy
because my name is also greg oh [ __ ] and
it's also my birthday i turned 22 today
congratulations you made it
congratulations what are you 99 damn was
that quick math online yeah it was mad
all right yeah i think so and and and
who else is uh who's elsa's birthday is
both of your birthdays harry potter no
that's me
moo lou who is this
is it his birthday yeah i've been saying
it wrong for so long too what is this i
used to say see me lulu
did you watch this did you watch this
canadian show
no i haven't pulled up on my netflix
kim's i heard it's great i like him more
in that than in shanghai all right so if
we could just get some more action and
kim's giving me a way to get people
excited the mass but greg happy birthday
to you mike too my friend i hope you're
having a good birthday two great girls
go out to a bar no mass go kiss people
on the cheek yeah go lick someone lick
some people out in public go to texas
and do it
oh yeah and then knock somebody up uh
audi
a very happy birthday to you greg from
jaby army love from the jab oh look at
that way to go thank you so much for
being here from the jaby kawai camp i
don't see any ryan wright shout outs ah
they'll come they'll come someone said
they were watching since the very
beginning that's right that's what i'm
talking about thank you for being here
for so long that was me
amar deep ray hall happy birthday greg
been following your channel before john
became part of the squad he was kind of
always he was always
here let me clarify john started the
channel though john started it up from
the get-go and i said move out of the
way yeah let me take over john came up
with the name real and greg came in was
like real checks none of this would be
here if that were the case um
we were trying to start it together and
it was uh it was remember the first
video we put together john that took
like hours of revenue
i didn't know how to do any lighting or
anything i just found spent like eight
hours setting up everything and then for
our adventures and we never even put the
video up yeah
make sure you subscribe to the spanish
version el rejecto
i found some of that really old footage
too just recently i found like some of
the old dv tapes we used to shoot on and
uh some of the original footage so uh
maybe we'll do a bts at some point
perhaps but
we argued really hard over prometheus we
did that was a fun one that was a that
was terrible that was a great one it was
a great movie
did you really like it no
and then we uh and then john was in
college and so it sort of became a
situation where it was like
all right i just got to like go gung-ho
with this and take this into my own
hands for a while but john was like for
the longest time it's kind of this weird
flip situation that started happening
because john would come on and people
would be like john's a good guess what
does he have his own channel and i'll be
like well actually he he helped start
this guys and then
eventually we became you were heavier
back then too yes it was and i was
skinnier that's the funny part about
this journey do you guys call it baby
fat or puppy fat
called fat fat
no but you know that word isn't it from
houston
fat or baby fat uh typically i i would
go with baby that's what i said too
that's legit
i've heard about
i only discovered this like this morning
i've heard beached whale fat as well
that's racist that is
against whales
the whale community wait just
communications
is gonna be on a poster somewhere like
whales don't get enough respect but
anyway mar deep uh you don't have to
send us a vat sick what's a vat 69 is
that a alcoholic drink ooh maybe
but i appreciate that 69 hit hit the
cannon the cannon cuts every 30.
oh that doesn't have a thing
no that's the way all cannons are
unless you have some kind of hack jabby
koa with your experts there's no auto
power off uh feature in there you can we
could talk about that later so let's
just make 16
a tech tutorial it's a scotch whiskey
vet69 it's it turned off again no no no
it's just the live stream delay oh yeah
that's right
yeah that faked me out right there
because this is the livest of the last i
thought this would be the most focused
but today's the most unfocused and what
more can you ask for
saves all of his focus for his own
videos
living freak yeah you go on chaby's
channel you just gotta keep it it's like
it's very regimented
scooch scooch
you haven't been on the channel in like
two years
i'm sure it hasn't changed it's changed
completely it's even more strict now
there's a script your reactions are
mapped out in advance
people come on i'm like just just don't
lose frame and i'm cool you don't have
to do anything at all
living free living freak greg yeah
what's up man where the hell are chara i
don't know she's doing her own live
stream and your fiance uh fiance's at
work right now doing a live stream did
you not want to spend your birthday with
either of them definitely not achara
she's a pain in the ass that one yeah i
hate it
constantly imposing your opinions on
everybody else
just hear this adam so opinionated
thoughts on a chart so loud but uh no
i'm gonna be spending the night with my
fiance tonight just taking somewhere
special i don't know where sleepover
yeah sleepover across the hall that's
what we're doing chuck e cheese
i would love chuck e cheese a lot of
people don't know that about me
discovery zone i remember dz i don't
know i'm not experienced i've been
wanting to go back to laser tag but
chuck e cheese has always been a big
part of my heart hey sarah campbell
sarah one of our longest patron ejects
so far longest in height
happy birthday i hope all three of you
are doing well well are you are you jaby
i'm working on it
you look like joe pesci
[Laughter]
funny how funny how explain how how am i
[ __ ] funny to you
i have been waiting here
chopin she has the penguin
all right let's uh let's refresh this
yeah that was a joke
that was danny devito that was danny
pesci he was saying what you were doing
yeah joe patchy is the best yeah his
voice got like that in godfather no i
want him
godfather guys not godfather good
fellows
good fellows i mix them up all the time
uh uh can we scroll to the bottom of the
chat sometimes i watch godfather i'm
like where's ray leota i'm trying to do
can we actually pull it
well that's that guys we got glitches
glitches in the house
it just means they're resetting the
matrix
i already read one of the latest super
chats it says happy birthday josh
i think you're on the wrong stream but
we're going to take josh's super chat
today appreciate it buddy you are
absolutely a josh okay
you're a josh in another life
j entertainment wants justice for achara
justice for a child
she might be doing her own life still
gabriel collins thank you for the
spiderman no way home trailer reaction
love
mohith b the speedcuber says happy
birthday lots of happy birthdays i
appreciate it guys why are they saying
happy birthday a lot of emoji blocks i
appreciate it yeah let's see here
someone says i watched shongxi like
almost 12 hours ago and the music is
still wandering in my mind that makes me
happy to hear yeah isn't that good
all right let's go i don't know it
wasn't that good awesome
all right so we got two to uh in our
stream in our in our uh yeah stream labs
right now laboratory here so we're going
with the first hold up big mo logan says
you share a birthday with charlie sheen
yeah dude
birthday today too duh
charlie shane is that the joe pesci
penguin
winning tiger blood
happy birthday to the nbc oh gotcha now
i got you your joe pesci is my charlie
sheen
destined destin hypothetical if marvel
studios said the mcu was finished after
end game would you have been satisfied i
say yes the infinity saga had a defined
beginning and end
it was a self-contained story with the
impact of star wars also happy birthday
greg thank you so much no one says the
music was mediocre i think it would have
been okay if um if it ended after end
game because i'm trying to think were
there any characters that didn't really
have a
a plot line in their solo movies or
standalone movies that were not finished
off captain marvel
it was kind of finished and i just told
her origin story
it's also gustavo lima's birthday that's
awesome to hear i love you i don't know
how long it is
it ended on uh guy in middle sounds like
ron burgundy that's you ron burgundy and
i'm the one with the ron burgundy shirt
yeah
uh no i think it would have been ah i
mean i would not have been satisfied i
don't think the mcu should ever end i
think it's never going on forever ever
forever ever
going to keep going as long as that bank
is working i think yeah that's right
i i think like yeah if they had
culminated with end game it would
certainly still be like a significant
thing but i feel like part of the marvel
story is then going how are they going
to proceed after end game what's what's
going to be the new so like i feel like
part of that sort of like growth and and
frontier like you know approach to like
how are we going to keep these crazy
serial stories going as part of the
drama here's a question about endgame do
you think at all i love when you look at
me like iron man do you does anyone else
think does anyone else think iron man
was a little bit selfish in saying that
they had to bring back people after his
kids were born
just a little bit selfish sure
as opposed to bringing everybody maybe
maybe that was just maybe that was just
part of the point i mean so what his kid
was born he didn't need to risk it
because like there were people there was
like a whole bunch of fallout as
evidenced by uh
monica rambo's mom being gone yeah right
yeah and so there's a whole bunch of
fallout out of people not being there
and depression and whatnot you can
assume
so everyone should be brought back no
one's depressed uh yeah i mean yeah
bring back everybody they didn't say who
not to bring back though right
i'm just saying he didn't specify this
but don't bring these people back you
know basically that's what the whole
experience he said only bring back
people who were snapped it's also whitey
bulger's birthday oh no way
black mass let's watch it tonight that
was the one that made me the most
excited left or in here happy happy
birthday greg hope you have a great b
day and hi jaby a big fan of you you and
atari streams best content to watch
while i go to sleep jk you hear that i
don't know whether to be happy or
offended by that that's that's i mean
your streams put me right to sleep that
was live stream that would mean that you
have a very soothing voice i guess
i gotta work on that thing you could
read nighttime meditations
i'm trying to see who else's birthday it
is jerome boateng i don't know who that
is dude i love jerome boateng what does
he do
stuff
yeah he's alive three different energies
in this i think iron man was selfish all
right well marvel does not suck marvel's
amazing hey italy in the chat all of
italy here today thank you so much
i also saw somebody in the chat say that
marcel sucks and that's mean because
marcel's a great guy help you know that
those many of those ryan wright videos
were taken down
by youtube periodic me doing it youtube
periodically you guys get an email
that's like this video drastically
violates we realize it was posted a long
time ago and you probably didn't know
but if you're wondering where your video
went that most of them don't have ads
most of them are a lot of them were
taken down and i was like
what are you gonna do here's an end game
question how would batman beat iron man
with his fists with his mind does it
batman beat superman how would he beat
iron man he could beat iron man right
batman could beat anyone batman how
would he do it
would he would make like an iron bat
suit or something just like beat him at
his own game he would never make an iron
bat suit ever
okay then fine he would detain one
live-action example where that ever
happened
so unrealistic so implausible they would
never do that all right
take the rules seriously jt comic geese
come guys jt come guys
where does shangchi rank among solo
movies in the mcu number one oh yeah
every new marvel movie number one
number zero above number one um
negative two i don't know where would
you where would you rank a javi uh i
would put it
number two
really i like doctor strange that has a
special place in my heart is doctor
strange okay and so chiang chi is pretty
strong in terms of
confusion
in terms of like bonding moments i don't
know i don't know
that was just off the top of my head i'd
have to think about that for a while
shanghi was not my favorite mcu film um
there's like several others i would
watch first over and over again if we're
talking about solo origins yeah that's
the hard thing is like i have to think
about that for a minute so you got
captain america um shanghai was
definitely a better origin story than
the first captain america film
right uh i think iron man is probably
better than chongqi in terms of like
what do you call it an origin story film
yeah i think iron man is still my number
one mm-hmm if we're talking about solo
films yeah
iron man and then i would say
oh i actually enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
thor
i enjoyed it so much before he became
thor
i mean can you count guardians of the
galaxy yes absolutely so that was so
much more entertaining in terms of like
hahas i would say
as we said happy birthday to you mcu or
miku um i would say iron man
guardians of the galaxy black panther
than shang chi but you know the thing
shang shi has over the other iron over
the other mcu films is that first hour
and a half action is amazing it's some
of the best action in all the mcu films
yeah yeah no i totally agree i think i
mean i would say shang chi has the best
action out of any mcu movie
i can't i can't it competes with winter
soldier pretty hard yeah
i would say it's better than winter
soldier
you can see what's going on
that's true you're not in that green
grass that is true yeah that is true
happy birthday from indonesia yeah old
school fan right there
i think the tension that they ring out
of the fight scenes in winter soldier is
better because it's just so intense and
so like
whereas uh shang chi i just think the
choreography and the camera movement and
uh when did you cheer when did you cheer
while watching chongqi the fairy without
spoiling anything because no spoilers in
the chat it was the first fight that
shang-chi has yes but at what point did
you cheer the very end of it ah no like
ten seconds in neuron was like holy [ __ ]
this is what we're doing here
when i started realizing like these are
the fight scenes yeah
halfway through that fight halfway
through that fight i was clapping yeah i
started the applause in the [ __ ]
theater i was clapping i'm like oh wait
there's more okay there's more action i
gotta hold back a little bit as as we
were like uh yeah as it kept going i was
like oh [ __ ] and then they started doing
like crazy camera shots so i was like i
can't believe we're doing this yeah it
was pretty amazing pretty amazing it's a
top tener for me of the entire mcu the
entire mcu it's easy top ten maybe top
five for me thank you to everyone coming
in to say happy birthday that is gonna
store the dark guys whoever is here if
you can just hit the like button that
would mean the world just please if you
could hit the like button on the edward
norton hulk way better you know i liked
the edward norton hulk a lot everyone
when i first you've never finished it
what about i mean the finale is good the
finale the final i bought it on 4k
blu-ray and i got 30 minutes and i'm
like i got to do this you watched the
wrong 30 minutes the final the the
finale is great i think uh i think the
finale helped save a lot of the movie
like that was uh i remember the first
time i saw an incredible hulk in the
theaters i was really dazzled by that
finale yeah best mcu film hands down
i feel like without yeah
i feel like without the finale of stay
with confidence
the reason i think people were excited
for abomination to be in chongqi is
because that finale is so good okay i'll
go back and watch it like the movie
itself is kind of okay now but uh the
finale is good
i'll go back dude uh shouts out to
manila philippines we spent a long time
on that one question gregory tagarao hey
pinoy pride baby right pinoy pride in
the chevy
i hear nothing cry i just hear blanks in
between your sentences it's weird
sarah williamson i definitely
like it
happy birthday greg
thank you for all the work you put into
this channel tommy
yeah
john do your to your tommy wiseau had
taught in reading hi greg happy birthday
thank you for all the work you put into
this channel you express yourself and i
appreciate all you do did i tell you i
met him we all met him we've all met him
everyone's met tommy how did you meet
him if you live in los angeles you
probably met tommy
what a big foot of this area one of my
good friends is actually one of the
stars of his uh second film best friends
awesome oh cool kristen stephen simpion
she's a best friend of mine she's in the
movie best friends how ironic right and
so i was leaving the premiere of best
friends the party and he was walking
towards me and i'm like tommy and he
just kept going that was how i am oh
completely good
you judged me you met him but he didn't
meet you exactly same way i met stan lee
actually that's the direction i
appreciate it i meant to comment when i
met i didn't actually talk to stanley
but he was coming out of this little bar
in hollywood he had one lady in each arm
i swear to god like two hot babes i'm
like oh my god it's stan lee and he's
got two hot babes on his arms he's
amazing he was talking to you
no i swear i was getting a character for
that cameo
oh pranav bot thank you pranav
is a regular on my live stream
hey buddy happy birthday greg also uh
jaby you should definitely read this one
uh where did you start the sentence
also hello
uh what are you wearing we don't miss
you on jaby live achara is doing a a
worse job than you right now
okay
you know people can't read tones so when
you're like sarcastically mean
a lot of times it doesn't register so
i'm going to take this as sincere
that's your fault yeah
yeah man how do you feel right now i
feel great marvel happy birthday greg
thank you for all the work
we have read that don't change the
subject
you can't hide oh we're going up i
thought we're going down i was now
read krishna
krishna
he's a very uh he's a regular online on
my live streams on my channel jaby live
decided to raid happy birthday awesome
look at that thank you so much she's one
of the poor people
nation it seems like thank you all for
being here just hit the like button
that's all i ask for really for the
birthday it's a like oh gregory will
wish you have great sex if you
contribute in the super chats i wish you
great sex with whatever you want to have
sex with yeah and just saying that got
us so demonetized so appreciate all the
super chats
super chat quick before this goes
offline
thanks buddy more filipino love in the
chat a lot of pinoy pride in the chat
what i'm talking about
shouts out to the ogs from the ryan
wright
uh what did i used to say as the opening
what do i say now
what's going on reject name what's going
on reject nation greg and john here
today that's what i say yeah yeah
i hate when the coordination i
you'd spend so much time on it it was
you know what they say about this shark
machine
his dragon is the great protector
we got to do it we got to bring back
straight to the point i want to bring
that those straight to the point reviews
and then have most people go what the
hell is this honorary
people know what it is about i mean the
reasons to see intro was like i'm ryan
ryan i'm jerry let's hang out something
like that yeah no one really watched
those videos well you should go back and
build them up
shout out to the ogs from the ryan right
and reasons of jerry days happy birthday
my guy hope all is well swell on your
day cheat day today cheat day is
actually when i'm stressed out i don't
think you get an upload up and then i
just started going and eating a bunch of
chips
that's what happened oh that's what you
meant by i thought i thought your fiance
was going to be yeah
yeah she's she's she's going to be so
cool she is my birthday right i could go
cheat on you
olivia is a swinger
[Laughter]
reports in the chat what the hell what's
up dude thank you so much
i gotta pay it back then when you guys
did you like that black mirror episode
like you know
let's rank all the black mirror episodes
let's do it you're up to
um yeah i like that one a lot who was
the other uh other dude that he was
kissing yeah abdul mateen from candy man
aquaman
a lot of man watch man
yeah
oh yeah he's great matrix man he was
also in the watch the chicago seven
watchman i know i just said watchmen he
didn't he did they didn't he said watch
man i said watch man as a joke yeah go
you got it wrong you still got it wrong
why are you wearing sunglasses because
it amuses me
that's good thank you to everyone for
being here please go ahead hit that like
button who else we got who's next next
nerd happy birthday greg love you guys
so much can't wait to see shanghai
sunday i've wanted to ask why y'all use
made up names before it was uh we had
this like
silly pretentious reason
of uh you know you know what i'm talking
about jaby
i was like greg made up a character
named ryan wright and then john played
along and made up a character what is it
he's exactly the same but i was still
just like the straight man foil yeah and
so i went i went with a name i made up
in my childhood jaby kawaii and then
greg abandoned ryan wright and i'm like
[ __ ] you i'm keeping this it's jaby
kawaii i've got a thousand subscribers
there's too many people here now i can't
undo this yeah you need but no no this
is good because then you'll build up to
a point where you can eventually come
out as yourself you see like
ryan you're trying to say john
that you are living alive
ryan wright was very um that inverted i
didn't intend for it to go down that
path but when i realized if i could use
a fake name i could get away with saying
a lot worse kind of jokes and then
it's like i would bring on a lot of
female guests and a big part of the bit
was making them uncomfortable with
sexual jokes you could also get away
with doing terrible hip-hop that's true
and then yeah that was great thank you
um
happy birthday i really tried the
hip-hop actually but okay
man
happy birthday listen up all right
ryan's last offense is a gem
that was my one that i was only when i
was on beat four
the one that's black and white yeah that
was on beat for that one yeah
with like a candle in the background
yeah so
um yeah i i uh we were talking about
yeah i was doing that like the whole
point but then it got uncomfortable when
i would go places people thought i would
have to make a dick joke every time it
was hard coming up with dick jokes after
a while you're like do videos every day
it's hard coming up with it making the
sorry
jokes
are starting to feel forced man i i
can't i can't just make a dick joke
every day especially now the movies are
getting sick and it was left harder to
be sincere after a while so um but the
the good part is when i
when i just decided to stop that it
helped because um i didn't realize
there's gonna be this whole cultural
movement happening around this type of
behavior i didn't realize you two become
a censored so i was like oh good thing i
started i decided to just be myself and
also it helps in the regard of um
yeah you know like a lot of because some
people go back to those older videos and
i see those comments that come in pill
being like wow this guy seems like a
horrible human
i've changed that's not even my real
name
it's actually even a good thing i had a
different name just for that purpose
kristen thomas shout out from india
happy birthday greg does a normal work
day what does a normal work day look
like for you what was the moment for you
when you decided to be a full-time
whitetuber i just go is there a
spider-man video up all right let's
cover it and then two hours later i'm
done did you start off with like
transformers and you're really mad and
so you made a review of it and that's
how your channel blew up yeah that's
your story yeah yeah exactly good time
no alcohol required to be here
you had like a you're like a red bag
background the jump cuts were a little
delayed yeah
yeah
did you say it was hard for you to make
dick jokes out girl you got it
ryan wright would have noticed that yeah
yeah you're uh you're getting uh you're
you're being left in the dust there yeah
and at the end of your reviews you used
to go get gregified
yeah
exactly click here to get gregified uh
yeah i would um
a normal day for for us from when you
run reaction channels on a patreon is uh
wake up don't be stressed out yeah wake
up with anxiety splatter through your
notification belts keep checking what
did i do wrong
and then uh yeah we sally's in new york
man she can't come back on the channel
she's in new york so uh and then it's a
lot of uh you know thinking about you
know what to shoot what to edit and then
depending on the video can take an hour
to two to edit and then uh patreon is
the only one that has a schedule whereas
this is so sporadic i'm like oh this
came out it's gonna take a while to kind
of like this live stream yeah it's very
special this live stream these two hours
of this live stream are going to equate
to a normal eight to ten hours in a day
archer pa happy birthday greg what do
you say
thank you archer pa good to see you
again bud it's been a while since we've
seen you thank you greg is my real name
since you're vigilant watchful don't
even know what ryan stands for
it stands for caleb gutierrez thank you
caleb happy b day greg have a great ass
day bro you bro are you having a good
ass date as you're asking you're having
a good ass day bro great titty day oh
pecks
to the guy
what's going on
heroes reports that they edited nine
videos this week and uh
adam i think adam have like he is the
editor of those videos and he does a
great job but man
i love adam i love how martin s actually
knew which reference we were doing about
the jump cuts were a little delayed he
knew which one we were talking about
what was his outro who the jeremy
johnson jeremy jones i don't know i
think he took him a while to come up
with you just do a punch right yeah he
just punched the camera and fell over
he's like i think i got an idea he's had
the same intro and outro for like since
the beginning if it don't work don't
change it or however that phrase
actually don't broke
don't worry
if it don't work it'll work
just keep on failing man yeah we'll see
uh hey what a great name we'll see like
harry p ness yeah happy birthday what
will you do if toby and andrew aren't in
no way home leave shut down the channel
um
uh and do you think foggy's style of
fight scenes will clash with raymies my
biggest concern
what is foggy style fight scenes
uh i mean you know whatever the vfx team
comes up
i think john watts
is not as strong of a director as sam
raimi i feel like that's not a insult to
like the spider-man movies necessarily
or even tom holland it's just i think
that the composition that sam remy has
and the understanding with those first
two spider-man movies are just so much
more breathtaking and cinematic and
they feel more like like spider-man 2 is
so much it looks like a painting to me
and uh i do think his fight scenes are
are the best out of any of the
spider-man movies which one i think
spider-man 2 are the best spider-man
fights
like nothing tops just to me the entire
train sequence like all that leading up
to it when he's like on the ground and
he's just trying to get back on the
train and he's like webbing and he gets
up on there i think that whole fight is
just cool and then like it starts off on
the building going to the street and
going on a train and it's just
breathtaking to me it's still the best
one
and i i really do hope that this one
will have the best fight scenes out of
any of the john watts spider-man led
films and i feel like especially if
you're going to bring in toby maguire
they have to top it and if toby and
andrew honestly if if toby's not in it
i'm going to be really upset i could
kind of do like i really want andrew to
be in there but he's the one i could be
like okay okay if andrew wasn't okay i
can understand that's funny but toby has
to be i feel a reverse
i like andrew you prefer you want andrew
to be in there yeah i really really want
him to be in there because he's so happy
yeah he's so happy about being
spider-man you saw the comic-con footage
right because peter parker is not so
happy about being smart
i'm just saying like james dean parker
did you did you see his footage at comic
con when he pulled off the mask like he
was so happy to be spider-man like i
just want to see him back yeah whereas
toby maguire seems tired and
run down
all right let's keep going never lose
your nerds such people spoil end credits
already in thumbnails i just yeah i mean
um
i feel like just doing it on thursday is
not a good call yeah or even friday
this i like saturdays are like
a little more understanding yeah tiffany
hoffman wants you to bring back ryan
right for a couple minutes
uh yeah thank you tiffany uh i think we
did
i think we think we really explored that
we were just a little late to get into
your super chat but why don't you do
your dick joke click your wang your wang
p
click your wand
click this button by my wong to
subscribe
it only worked because you could put
this you would like do it like it would
be a close-up on me that you do yeah and
then you have the subscribers isn't it
sad that those are all gone now
i like the annotation it's so
frustrating you can mess around with
them more i got all these videos where
like i would put in a you know picture
picture where you could click on the
picture and picture now it just shows up
and it's [ __ ] weird it's like what is
that doing there why would he do
something so awful like that they should
leave the old ones as they were gary
phillips love your channels and
communities you guys are amazing people
god bless have a good day 20 super chat
thank you so much buddy thank you so
much man gary you seem like a good guy
too a lot of when people don't remember
that my name they call me gary that's
how it always goes so a lot of ways you
should the same name as me gary garrett
exactly shadow skull game
happy birthday john i love you so much
more than greg
thank you shadow skull game yeah you
know it's never too late to get your
gemini love in there so i appreciate
that that's what today is for all right
is my belated birthday
all right gary phillips back at it again
here is my question
uh what when do you think ghost rider
will appear in the mcu
i think
um i think you can go i think what's
gonna happen is multiverse of madness is
gonna be the thing
that starts setting you up for
more supernatural horror i think what if
that doctor strange episode was only
like the beginning of it but i believe
the supernatural hor because we're doing
multiverse and then we're segueing into
um supernatural horror what are you
doing with your hands i'm using i'm
learning to [ __ ] like trying to get
my thoughts out here
like multiple sephora because it's like
we've been setting up the multiverse
pretty much is what we've been focused
on right from loki
to uh now we got spider-man no way home
coming out seems like eternals is really
going to be touching on that even end
game was the first thing to really set
that up and then now we have to
introduce this other element of
supernatural horror and i think that's
going to come in the form of doctor
strange multiverse of madness which will
put a little bit it's not going to end
the multiverse but it's going to put a
little bit of a stamp on it to be able
to start segwaying down this other path
where we can get films like ghostwater
we can get films like blade things that
are or moon night even like things that
are just a lot darker in tone
so yeah do you really think they're
going to explore the multiverse
[Laughter]
no can you read can you read shadow
skull games thing again but with drax's
voice greg can any of us do it like how
does drax's voice sound again nothing
gets over my head happy birthday john i
love you so much more than greg
he's so sincere it sounds like yeah not
bad at all it's not bad at all i i want
part of me just to go back to gary
phillips really quick i i wonder if even
in multiverse matt like there's so much
in the imagery that the the limited
imagery they've
clicked
what happened there's so much in the
limited imagery they've released that
reminds me of that tentacle shot from
the previous uh from the most recent
what if episode so part of me wonders if
we will in some way breach into like the
hell dimension in this movie even if
it's not like a direct like mephisto a
ghost writer are here but like i feel
like we'll see
the place the realm where all that
originates did anyone else feel like the
part where doctor strange absorbs the
tentacles did it at all feel like hentai
for anybody else or is it just me not
all tentacles or hentai
believe it or not tentacle stuff existed
before that's true that's true
squids octopi
the common misconception out there
really it's not this hentai begat
i mean you know there's some deleted
scenes i think jaby's appearance today
is is a great example of what his
channel is like so yeah be sure to
subscribe to get jabbing absolutely
i appreciate everyone in this in the
live stream chat uh i've seen all these
really kind comments coming in thank you
so much that's really sweet of you guys
thank you hey real real quick to co-op
to that k-pop audience uh you share a
birthday with joy from red velvet oh
cool that's good to hear so yeah get
your camera are we doing that game i
still got it don't worry guys we will
bring back sally when she's back in town
sus jaby oh she's uh she's she's always
been an amazing person
i think jaby's pulling up aka lucky
right now yeah let me show you guys what
i'm talking about i'm like i know what
it looks like on the stream
what does gravity mean to those mauricio
destree these are the people you share
birthdays with
a.k.a luck says that it felt like hentai
thank you guys so much for coming in
thank you thank you rahul happy birthday
youtube buddy happy birthday okay psych
happy birthday josh what the [ __ ] is
going on maria hammond's here she'll be
like hey maria
real quick real quick to the indian fans
in this in the chat right now greg
shares a birthday with sad guru
oh dude look out now exactly look what
maria hamming
this friggin mask i can't see it
is greg and john out of rick and morty i
see myself in the background isn't that
cool look at that look at how beautiful
that is hey bogey brothers thank you and
please don't spam you spam you get hit
you get blocked bogey brothers that's
where is your shout out
and uh justin what's up buddy yeah
birthday with that's awesome dude big mo
logan one year ago i told you to press
ctrl plus to zoom oh yes no no no the
chat thingy i want this this covered up
thank you
you are so insecure about your crotchel
region thank you maria you're so sweet
there's so much to intimidate anybody
you know you know yeah you don't want to
make everyone feel bad about their
penises
omnimedia's saying it was the veteran
think of hentai uh okay i don't think uh
no way home is getting pushed back i
believe it's sticking the release date
no way home does not remind me of hentai
it reminds me absolutely of hentai i'm
gonna do an ending experio setup i'm
gonna do an endian explain of venom two
uh and post it the day before the movie
comes out yes
she posted the monday before you guys
put it right there
post credit scene
furiosa looks like we both have the same
birthday date happy birthday thank you
furiosa it's a great name
where's this from where's she uh where's
it from m-y-r
great question let's not take too much
time to figure this out i appreciate you
being here period smooth panda happy
birthday greg quick question what actor
would you want to play miles morales
spider-man
will smith that's in malaysia
donald glover can i don't think donald
glover would be a good prowler and i
think he's now a little too old to play
miles morales right because he was he's
originally championing to beat miles
morales he's grown his beard out huge in
public so it's too late now and even
though uh donald glover is aaron davis
established in the mcu i can't see him
being prowler for some reason what about
what about michael b jordan he hasn't
done anything in the mcu yet
nothing of notes that i can think of
yeah
nothing twice who could be a good
who's the i don't know i'll be honest i
have no idea who would be the right one
if they could find someone who was like
half puerto rican half black that would
be really cool if you could find like an
unknown if they could find an unknown
halfway and half black like someone
who's mixed ethnicity because daniel day
lewis because the common one is to go go
for the you know like just a full black
actor but i think if you can find
someone who's actually half an hour it
could be hard to find but i feel like in
new york you can probably find it yeah
there's a lot of puerto rican black
people out there i mean i think it would
be cool if they got an up-and-comer to
do it yeah personally or somebody who
doesn't have a lot of credit people will
watch it
it doesn't matter who yeah i didn't know
who tom holland was until i heard he was
cast how about denzel washington's
kid how about o'shea jackson oh [ __ ]
kevin hart's kid yes
yes kevin hart i think kevin hart would
be a funny uh uh uh miles morales
know the
mysterious midnight oh thank you buddy
you really gotta wish him good sex in
your birthday wishes thank you mister
this is gonna be a mysterious minute you
know my favorite my favorite game to
play is board game midnight taboo
who's going off topic now no i'm not
it's called mysterious midnight
and it's mysterious the things that
taboo makes you uh you know admit and
stuff so yeah i would say mysterious
midnight thank you so much man that's
very very generous of you i really
appreciate it utkarsh gupta latest wes
anderson movie in the works has an even
bigger cast tom hanks margot robbie
scarjo and more to be added plus his
regular uh his regulars really excited
for it it's just going to be uh is he
the one that did mortal kombat this is
going to be knives
paul
west anderson
the ws stands for the beginning and end
of the west no he did boogie nights
right that's the way that's the one this
was a hypothetical that was pitched on
twitter i don't remember
but i've always wanted to see this
happen is someone said paul thomas and
paul w s anderson should both write a
script and then trade them and each
direct each other's scripts to see how
those movies turn out
um but i've been hearing a lot about
this new wes anderson movie i like wes
anderson movies quite a bit
his budapest hotel movie yes i have seen
his birthday did you like
that
the best one
bottle rock gets one i thought i thought
grand budapest hotels best one uh
rushmore rushmore was uh what definitely
one of my favorites from him as well as
royal tenenbaums i did not finish the
royal aquatic or whatever it was called
life
i'm in the minority on them you like
this movie oh my god
i was just bored to
i really liked uh was moonrise kingdom
or something or another that's a good
one i like that one's kingdom yeah yeah
with the cub scouts with bruce willis
bruce was great in that marvel marvel
uh yeah i would i'm very especially for
the fact that he got tom hanks like
those i mean has wes anderson worked
with scarlett johansson before yes i
can't remember where i don't think they
have so i'm pretty sure they have but
that is a pretty big cast that's huge
natalie feel like i've seen oh no i'm
thinking of the the one with them what
do you think of natalie portman i'm
thinking of the german movie i really do
think that uh oh you're thinking of jojo
or yeah jojo rabbit that's what i was
thinking it has some wes in it i really
do think that margot robbie is one of
the best actresses working
she's got that magic movie star quality
where it's like she can really act but
she's also got that just
inimitable charm and she's like her
versatility is so impressive oh yeah i
saw wolf of wall street i thought she
must have been a real new yorker yeah
yeah and that's such a role where like
it would be very easy for the
performance not to even register yeah
and it does oh i guess they've never
worked together and then you go to i
tonya and you got it yeah all right
looked it up yeah you nailed it there
you go right on time marvel back in here
second super chat here forgot a question
i was wondering happy birthday to tyrone
magnus's friend thanks cedric uh forgot
a question
i was wondering if any of you have a
favorite story from a movie slash tv
shows production
i'm a major fan of that christian bale
rant
just listen to it once a year that was
like the one of those rare things where
we just could not i know john and i just
could not stop listening to it if we
play it i can i could probably say
everything that's going to be i just
know it's my heart by this point
yeah that is the one of the funniest
things ever and the remix we listen to
remix listen to the remake we were
really into that christian bale right
now mine is from royal uh not royal
tennis was it called i heart huckabees
that was oh god david or russell going
on you like that one i was so scared
it just reminded me of my home life
growing up
back it made me feel warm and fuzzy
exactly that's like it's family right
there
yeah no i look i love it i love it
because it's like it's one of those
things where he just lost it in a way
that i mean i don't even know how he
redeemed himself from that one but i
just loved it yeah he's known to be one
of the worst people to work with david
o'russell really i've heard like his his
stories are so public of how
awful he's been to like cast and crew
yeah george clooney refuses to work with
him because he how he saw him treat a
background
background people like push someone and
i'm like how did he rise to this auteur
status i know it seemed like this
behavior was going like pretty much
i know someone who's a working
screenwriter and he was on stage with
david o'russell and they almost got in a
fight on stage because he was just being
a dick to him and putting him down and
he was like literally on the stage it's
like do you want to go outside now so
what does jennifer lawrence have that
makes it like harmonious
to work with him because it seems like
she wouldn't want to put up with that i
could see why christian bale gets along
because he's just so intense and yeah
he's known to be hard to work with too
um but yeah
anyway twinsanity bros happy birthday
greg also curious on which movies you
are most excited for that releases this
year besides spider-man and eternals i'm
gonna be honest i i keep wanting to
watch the green knight and i haven't
seen that yet and it's like really
bumming me out that i haven't seen it no
i want to so bad the kind of movie my
brother would hate oh jesus
such a boring move oh my god slow get it
going you watch like four and a half
hour indian joints they're like they're
exciting
that's true there's a lot
i agree night i had the same experience
i had with the suicide squad where at
the end of green night at the end of the
night i got scared because i was the
last thing i expected to hear no because
i'll explain at the end of green night i
was scared because i was like i am not a
big fan of this movie and i'm so scared
that i'm gonna be the only one and i
went on youtube and it really felt like
that for the longest time i kept looking
for something to validate my perspective
and the only the closest i could get to
it was perry nemeroff who was like
i didn't love it i'm like thank you i'll
take that win that was all i needed was
one person to sort of validate my but i
think you guys will like it i i i like
the slower movies a lot more than my
brother that's that's one thing i'm not
opposed to slower movies i just didn't
like that one you say that and then you
often don't like them
i love mad max that's as slow as it gets
the first one the one the one with tom
hardy yeah that's
snape eric boss is what you call the
king of the breakdowns
i like mitchell black that's a pretty
slow movie three hours of
slowness yeah that's true so
did you like the irishman i did actually
slow movie i did like i didn't like
martin scorsese's movie about flowers
what john has colorful scrunchies that
is very true yes it is yeah i got a
whole pack of them james goings goings
happy birthday also thank you buddy they
also did you real time stop yourself
from swallowing when you stopped
yourself in the dr strange what if yes
we were doing a um we were doing a
reaction to the
new rockstars breakdown and there was
something that was about to come out of
me then i realized oh wait that's a
spoiler for something that people
haven't seen yeah yeah
and i was like just don't say it yeah
yeah yeah i had to i had to catch myself
in the moment as a real human we gotta
talk about that after the stream because
i'm so confused by that
what because in the breakdown from new
rock stars he he alluded to shanghi
well yeah i was about to clarify
something because he hadn't seen it
okay eric voss hadn't seen it he was
theorizing i had seen it yeah and so i
was about to clarify then i was like
oh wait yeah it's not out yeah stop me
from giving away spoilers i'm like can i
say yes or no she's like absolutely not
people haven't seen it yet i'm like damn
it
happy birthday eric voss
you've met um ryan george man that's
probably out of anyone you've met online
online that's out of anyone i've ever
interviewed him anyone you've ever met
that is probably the only one i've ever
been like a little a little jealous i
tried to set you up
yeah but i don't want to go through the
hassle i want you to charity you're like
i don't want to follow in your footsteps
jaby yeah i want ryan george to come to
me no but he was one of the nicest dudes
ever like we did a half hour interview
on get jet what he's canadian he has to
be i heard something else i'm so glad i
got clarification he's in some hentai
you heard cuckold yeah
he's a cook yeah he it was an interview
on get jabby and he was like really
really fun to interview for like 30
minutes straight very like very down to
earth guy
he just talked to himself the whole time
[Laughter]
caleb gutierrez i feel strange
messing up the spell is a nexus event to
start the multiverse to justify loki's
ending and all the timelines are having
nexus events
well i think though why it's not a nexus
event i think eric voss actually
explained it pretty well was that what
strange is doing with the time stone is
only on his immediate direct timeline
he's not affecting really
this
drastic timeline he's not able to change
absolutes basically
well he does technically if he actually
the way it ends yeah it's like he
finally finds the way to actually change
it but at the cost of just wrecking the
entire timeline yeah yes
but of just that universe yeah yeah yeah
and then on the spider-man side of
things like i don't know i i don't know
if that would constitute as a nexus
event because it seems like nexus events
are already happening
i don't know like i almost feel like the
nexus event in the spider-man side would
be when he's revealed i guess we just
don't know exactly where on the timeline
spider-man no way home is taking place
yet yeah absolutely what if that was the
very first marvel film you ever watched
was spider-man no way home it will be
for someone you know one of the greatest
one of the one one of my favorite
youtube videos i've ever seen was a guy
who watched avengers end game without
having seen anyone his brother was
someone's brother right that was a great
video yeah
yeah
someone's like have you seen doctor
strange
is that a is that a joke
that's so funny
did you read that one from caleb
gutierrez yeah you did okay pixel monkey
gaming happy birthday greg do you guys
think we will see an easter egg of miles
morales or spider gwen in the new
spider-man movie i think an easter egg
of miles morales is very likely they've
already had the easter egg of miles
morales in spider-man home uh yeah
homecoming with uh aaron davis
a you have aaron davis which is already
an easter egg in it of itself and then b
um he references his nephew which is
only aaron which is only miles morales
so yeah it's already been an easter egg
for moss morales and by this point i'd
imagine that miles kid's probably
growing up a little bit i think it'd be
really cool if you bought if you brought
donald glover back even for like a
little bit even though i know he had a
little bit of a
some tension with marvel there for a
second when it came to his deadpool show
and then that fell through but don't
worry that that's effects maybe they
were not as involved with that because
they didn't care as much how are you
doing do you think do you think black
widow will make an appearance in no way
home yeah
she's going to be the new mentor
with a contract in her head
don't sign it peter
you messed him with the contracts peter
don't take the dual release strategy
peter
big mo logan in the chat says meeting
ryan george is not super easy
or a convenience no i appreciate varun
kumar happy birthday greg from will
smith channel i don't get it dude will
smith's channel wished you happy
birthday oh thank you that's a big deal
thank you or he discovered we were in
will smith's video did you know about
that i know we were in one of them yeah
i don't think he edits those so i don't
think he had anything
he chose to put us in the videos he was
like you got to put these [ __ ]
in this i curated these reactions
exactly
oh yeah i forgot to bring the donuts
you are going to bring the class donuts
i forgot to bring the class donuts my
bad will smith sits there on his laptop
editing every video he puts out yeah
will smith is that's how he gains so
much weight yeah well maybe his q maybe
one of his other kids does it like jack
black he wakes up with the same anxiety
we do
what do i have to make for content
responding responding and pinning
comments
we got birthday wishes from poland greg
did you like the shape of water tan i
did lo i love the shape of water another
one that jaby does not like that i
really liked you don't like fantasies
jaby i hated that yes this is illogical
why would the
as soon as he ate the cat i'm like why
would you sleep with this dude why why
why would you do that to yourself all
right did she did he did he eat the cat
after
satan's he ate the cat then they slept
together in the shower oh yeah then
never mind
exactly
undoes the whole movie now it doesn't
matter i'm sorry
it's a big gap
and for a hot second
for a hot second during this i was
reading a super chat and i got lost in
your conversation when i checked back in
i was like the hell are they talking
about and then i realized oh yeah hentai
shape of water
uh righteous rob been watching your
channel since the amazing spider-man 2
reaction can you screenshot lana's
because she hey lana she because she put
a super chat in there but forgot to put
a question in there yeah
screech
yeah if you guys forget to put a
question in the super chat that's
totally fine i'll read righteous rob
been watching your channel since the
amazing spider-man 2 reaction oh thank
you that is funny how the amazing
spider-man that brought in a lot of
subscribers that in the raid that and
the ray were like they were massive
subscriber games years ago
and amazing spider-man 2 is considered
like
one of the worst spider-man i still
haven't seen it what i haven't seen i
love andrew garcia we haven't seen an
amazing spider i watched the first one
twice to make up for it
that's the same thing well i mean you
gotta at least watch it they're very
good for the happy birthday donuts you
gotta at least watch i will
or or or watch like a i cinnamon studio
or something i'll watch it i'll watch it
or you can watch like a new rock star's
breakdown no my buddy ilrom was the
devil of spider-man and spider-man too
chaby did you just get eye surgery
he did that's why he doesn't want you oh
yeah i got laser eyes i don't want to
blow out this whole set have a good day
at work alex william and uh sammy wants
to know if he's like the internals
character sammy wants to know if greg's
gonna do a reaction video to your
wedding video i'm going to be doing a
reaction to something the day of the
wedding i'm going to react to it we're
going to finish this question now oh
yeah uh
how are you how old are you now also are
you more hard for batman or no way home
um i like how you ran out of room at the
end of the video yeah you're not as
clever that's how you fit in there i
don't want to i don't want to super chat
more let me how do i
get that smart that's smart man
um i think i would i'm 31 i would say
i'm 31 and uh what are you more hyped
for
batman because i know less about it
is that a joke are you being serious i
can't tell i feel like you sound sincere
are you being serious i'm i'm figuring
that out right now
i feel like batman is just naturally
more my jam
but it's weird i'm more ex i'm more
i'm pretty
no way home is i'm more excited for in
terms of uh like just like what the hell
is this gonna be is this gonna really
work and the idea of like
you know uh a moment in movie history of
crossover and breaking open the door for
that i'm excited for them for very
different reasons
but i don't know i i guess right now i
would say in this moment in time i'm i'm
likely to fluctuate i've seen i know so
much more about no way home so that's
what i'm more excited for because i want
to see that fulfilled
but i'm sure like after the second
batman trailer in october i'm gonna be
like all right maybe it's batman
for me for me it's easily no way home
yeah nothing like that's been done
before they've done batman movies before
and so no way home they've done like 20
spiderman
but not like this yeah that's true
that's that point yeah you know what i'm
saying except for spider-man and
spider-verse right you know
that's the card
cartoons no one's watching that no one's
watching what it's only one layer or
higher uh hey tdk rise is happy birthday
to you as well turning 33 today oh yeah
and jaby according to falden 8 looks
like a member of dap punk where are you
where are you punk uh over here in the
chat
people john doesn't make the folks clear
here
in the regular chat in the chat chat
all right back to the super chat squad
squad hey the real thumbnails love your
channel happy birthday many more to come
started watching since the big four time
to get it get lit have a great day thank
you so much the big four
the big four big four and no longer the
big four we've disbanded oh we're going
to be like the eternals
we swore never to intervene
until now i started reading that which
one the eternal the neil gaiman
that's the one that's the one i ordered
is it good i like it i hope the movie's
not like that though oh good all right
so is this so should i read it should i
read a different eternals comic book
that's the only one i've read but i'm
just saying like i like the comic on its
own but i hope that's not the movie
gotcha so
well it won't be they they they cobble
together
pieces of all their plot lines no i
think the director's gonna do her own
thing in many ways big mo logan
but i miss uh i miss i missed those four
what are you talking about i don't know
what the big four is before
everyone had a reaction channel
oh yeah tyrone magnus you and uh
gatormark gator martin and akasan yeah
because he's still there
he's still there yeah gator's still
they're all still going but now there's
like a gazillion people doing it mm-hmm
and now they've got two yeah
actually i like four channels
yeah thanks
really not helping with the
overfluctuation that we're having here
saturation what did i say real
fluctuation saturation true saturation
good point big mo logan big mo logan
happy birthday yeah yeah people are
staying in the chat where's my presents
what are my presents oh you want one
it's coming on sunday i mean i've got
yours here if you wanted what do you got
all right i'll go get it where's it it's
in the front room i thought you're
joking go get it boy all right go get it
all right we'll keep reading these happy
birthday we share it with charlie sheen
yeah that's right oh it's your birthday
too happy birthday to you too buddy
davey84 drake's album is aoty hold on i
need to adjust this oh my god john's
like
and of course john i always look forward
to your reactions and reviews
he super chatted a whopping 20 bucks
thank you so
much be a receipt in here john john i i
couldn't scroll down you got to fix the
live stream
scroll down to what i'm here to fix
everything oh damn all right what the
hell is that jesus let's do the last of
these super chats here i know we got
more i think you got somebody oh 12.
1205 likes thank you guys so much that's
something bigger hitting that like
button hey where did the check is that
is that going to get this demonetized
whatever's in that box no it's not it's
not thank you guys so much for being
here
if you're if you haven't hit the like
button yet please hit that like button
james james 13. all right happy birthday
to youtube buddy where's eric horse
so we did davey
we did davey drake's album his album of
the year yeah he got up there all right
cool and we're on a l one album
though all right so james james ao1227
which variant would you rather see in
the multiverse madness tom cruise iron
man joaquin phoenix is doctor strange or
john krasinsk as cap
uh
i would rather see
tom cruise as iron man personally
i feel like krazynski would be the most
game
actually
but to do i take it back joaquin phoenix
says anybody i'd love to see him do
something
not the joker yeah anybody else ah bruce
wayne
i don't know i'd be kind of down for
krasinsky's cap that would actually be
my personal favorite that sounds like
the weird that sounds like the most
normal one but it's actually the one
joaquin phoenix as vision
no wanda that's why i meant wanda
i i think tom cruise's iron man would be
humorous it would overpower everything i
don't think it would be actually cool i
think it would it would be funny it
would be a yeah it would be like a
camera what if what if you funny one tom
cruise what if he uh you shaved his head
and
like
shave his healer's hair a little bit
like he's kind of bad
you're doing that you know i'm saying
yeah yeah i get what he's doing he's
like a producer i got the joke now yeah
yeah i got there
all the film crew's you know making a
movie man is also les grossman yeah i
like it i i think john krasinski would
be great because john krasinski if he's
not he would just
richards then that would be an ultimate
troll but if he was reed richards that
would just be fun
um he would just stare at the camera
wouldn't he i'm probably i think john
kasich is the one watching the office
he'd deliver some good news
and then i would say joaquin phoenix's
doctor strange would probably be my
second pick pretty nikki jabby greg and
john together what an awesome treat
can't stick around but about to go watch
shang chi don't want to be spoiled adore
you guys adore you too thank you so much
i love you wait a minute did we read the
james james 13 one yes
dude we did it he did i read it i said
hey he contributed 20 bucks happy b day
and thanks for representing hop up hanoi
all right cool cool thank you so much
now you got to read it as drax
that's the panel it's been said
happy b day thanks for representing
maria oh yeah
and of course john
i always look forward to your reactions
and reviews that's actually a pretty
good impression i will not join the
suicide squad
i can't even see you right now yeah he
went to the snyder cup
bruce campbell is captain america jay
george that's a great that's a great
call i would definitely and maria wants
you to upload the the thingy for
unboxing the rick and morty thing okay
yeah we're gonna get do it
okay
yeah i know we got more super chats we
got more things to go through but we're
going to open john's little hold up
we're almost caught up on this gonna be
the weirdest gift no there's more it
just has a refresh there's there's a
good amount more hair we'll kill this
little window here for just a second i
didn't wrap it because i i know that i
don't give a [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ]
it's inside of a box
that's technically right natural purpose
flower all-purpose natural flower
um and if there's a receipt inside just
uh give it to me
really quick all right let's see hey
sarah thanks for being here i can't see
how much of a discount i got imagine if
jaby took over the real rejects hmm oh
let's not people would be like i'll just
go watch get jabbing guy hates marvel
what and slow moving films
this guy hates cinema
just because i didn't like the green
knight
everyone thinks i don't like marvel now
hold that against you
what the [ __ ] is this it's for your back
yeah what is this that's for your back
it's for your back
what do you mean how does this work you
just roll on it it's got a divot for
your spine and so it's like a foam
roller but it's this is specifically
designed for
this is very much a john present like
only only john would come up with
something like
you for my birthday you gave me
something that wasn't like a nerdy
t-shirt or something like that so i was
like got him a massage gun yeah so i was
like okay you know i know that often
times i see your massage
and i raise you all right
but like it helps me out a lot and like
you have some back pain you know it's
like this for like different sections of
the back yeah the big one no no no the
big back to the low back
the big one is the smaller they are the
more deep tissue is the ice oh really so
it just rolls right down the spine yeah
so you just roll yeah you kind of you
sit what are you not getting about this
concept greg
you want a quick demo do a quick demo it
has this one and it's got one of those
that's kind of like there's there's also
a small one for the camera adjuster that
you had yeah there's a small one for the
cats in here look oh they could go
running yeah that's the deaconess roll
on it so they say you know the deep
tissue
all right guys john's gonna do a rep uh
john's gonna oh geez all right give me
that really you'll be able to see that
yeah all right so look
john i just went off john yes thank you
so much for the present john i really
appreciate you're welcome you got to do
it with us i'm gonna enjoy it here it's
not like the flashiest thing i'm just
like john scoots your chair back okay
jaby scooch to john's mike
sit down yeah yeah just screw to john's
mic
john's gonna do a representation for us
all right give me the biggest
demonstration
what did i say representation so
training it's training not practice
all right so you get down here you get
your little wheel
and then you kind of oh you got stuff
like this yourself you don't need them i
never saw that before
[Laughter]
look at john go
look at john girl
can you actually see him
there's a preview right there
very cool all right take off your shirt
and do it now
yeah only if it's
hold on no only if they super chat 100
[Laughter]
i'll
here you go yeah that's the basics of
how that works all right am i done with
this post yeah oh greg's doing it now
yeah yeah yeah try it out
do your do your chest instead if someone
super chats 150 greg has to take off his
shirt
yeah you just kind of align yourself
yeah it takes a little getting used to
but
that's easy oh yeah that's nice yeah
oh yeah
it's a nice little i don't
you know you get yourself a little
stretched out you get a couple cracks in
there
you know
you can land your head on it we got a
live stream to run here like a pillow
it's like a pillow
so i will resume my position
i i hope it's i hope it's practical
guys i'm doing a giveaway who wants this
can we get the crotch cover up the
crotch cover back up we are not covering
the crotch
all right all right flev dorian
john get us reorganized here would you
we didn't read that yet yeah we did uh
no flying we didn't read that
oh char likes it are you going down the
road uh we're going oh we got a few in
here is the char done with their live
stream achara get over here you're doing
your live stream are you did you think
you could just stop working in
over here
charlie doing wait hold up is the news
thing out hey joseph
okay so we got something break no no no
i'm just making sure the new thing
second one from flev
is this the first time we've seen jaby
in the real reject studio in two years
yeah the bollywood vfx video yes and why
don't we get more collabs since you guys
are covering almost the same stuff
that's exactly why we don't get more
collabs
you can benefit more often
i didn't know that and then we are doing
i was just i was just sitting there
confused
we do the same stuff a lot so yeah you
cover new rock stars i cover new rock
stars and then we cover it together
yeah
that's what i want
but that's that's the simplest way to
answer your question thanks flev yeah
hitman hudson sorry i can't afford more
that's okay buddy
sorry sorry cam but i should be sorry
yeah what the [ __ ] is your what gives
why insult us why even show up nah dude
like this the fact that you care enough
at all yeah man
i'll refund you sorry i can't afford
more but i just spent all my money on
joining the patreon this little known
rap group called the real rejects no
[ __ ] thanks dude
happy birthday greg so hype for the
wheel of time i can't wait to be one of
those annoying book readers yes nah dude
that's a great thing to be as long as
you are able to enjoy the show yourself
then i'm a-okay with that
smoove panda 94. happy birthday greg my
question is which actor would you like
to see play miles morales fight i don't
think we covered that one yet
there's got to be one john just type in
on google okay um marlon brando uh who
can
or uh who top contenders to johnny miles
and ross mel gibson
louis ck
peter quill top contenders to play miles
morales we're going to solve this right
now
justice smith of course i was going to
joke justin you open up the the link
there so we can see their faces animated
times that's how you judge i had a
feeling the kid from stranger things oh
damn we got 13 14 likes thank you so
much guys how about tyrone magnus
tyrone would be a great prowler so
justice smith is on here
maybe
renny felis i think he would be good
he's from runaway series he'd be great
and you get another recasting mcu stuff
okay alex r hibbert i wouldn't be bad
our chase how about jordan peele
taylor james will that guy's a really
good accent taylor james doesn't mean i
feel pretty young
he said he's not going to act anymore i
think he really said he's not going to
do on screen anymore
caleb mclaughlin from stranger things
would actually probably be like the
smartest pool i think because you get
someone from a really popular franchise
put them in this one yeah that could get
people excited and i think from the work
we've seen him do he could probably pull
it off and he is different and it is
different from who he is in uh stranger
things yeah absolutely yeah i think we
fulfilled this super i think shamiq more
would be cool just to bring him in from
the spider verse
just get him actually like i don't know
i think that could be actually just kind
of a cool turn although i don't know he
looks a little too old now yeah that's
the problem i feel like if you're gonna
introduce someone who like looks young
you want them to grow you need someone
who has that tom holland effect where no
matter how old he gets he looks like
he's 12. he looks like a kid yeah
nips too good for you my top 10 movies
in the mcu are end game infinity war
guardians of the galaxy shanghai thor
ragnarok captain winter soldier dr
strange spider-man homecoming black
panther and captain first avenger also
first time don't know been watching for
years happy b day thank you so much
nip's too good for you dude that's like
ripping on my
my quote there nipple chills thank you
so much dude chili chili nips and flevy
d's back pepflep d uh no seriously i
like jaby's streams because it's nice to
hang out with you and achara watch some
memes and have some fun and you do have
a soothing voice and an infectious laugh
great laughters in the alba fan indeed
you should hear my sister's laughter
that's the most soothing she laughs yeah
she laughs she's great alice i make her
laugh i've never heard her you gotta
learn how to make her laugh
yeah i learn how to put a smile i just i
just see a scowl in here smile
continues sorry for talking only about
jaby
that's okay he's here
i have i have a people-pleasing thing
where i'm like i hope he doesn't feel
left out yeah
i don't get it
i don't think he feels left out no one's
talking enough about me on greg's
birthday
i don't get to interact much with jaby
because super chats are difficult in my
area jaby uh you and achara started
watching aot but stopped have you
continued or planned to attack on titan
oh we have not continued i'm at episode
50 i believe
i forgot where we still i thought about
resuming but i haven't picked it up yet
i love attack on
wow how could you did you watch the uh
vfx guys react make the a real attack on
titan no is it good oh that's pretty
sweet i haven't watched that video yet i
haven't seen it i've seen the thumbnail
pop up a bunch of times on youtube
recommendations i'm like i'll get to it
no i haven't seen it yet
i'd love to calm down youtube i'll get
to it calm down youtube is that the end
of the super chats no
definitely not it's like
4k in super chats what does that mean
they're in really high resolutions
super chats are
zoom in as far as you want four favorite
animated movie i think my top favorite
animated movie is fox and the hound
iron giant ah aladdin oh yeah aladdin i
really love and aladdin are my two
favorite animated well actually disney
animated my favorite uh animation of all
time is kung fu panda oh i like that i
would love to be uh i've been with
cinematic universe but i like to make a
surprise cameo in i would i would say i
would love to be in uh
i mean mcu is the most obvious one so
i'm gonna say the batman the pirates of
the caribbean franchise let's just see
what happens there what was the question
greg sucks you gotta show that comment
it's it's it hides it's being hidden
it's being hidden you gotta [ __ ] what
does greg suck follow up uh so joan t1
uh you can suck my dick
jay arts yes corridor crew absolutely
big mo logan we are not four thousand
dollars of super chat you're way off on
that
[Laughter]
just remember youtube takes ninety
percent uh let's see here
uh r34 gtr you all need to watch titus
this season lots of death wow that's a
surprise one
oh i think what happens is that like uh
the currency conversion of it all can be
kind of confusing you know yeah absolute
vodka i would give shanghi a 7.5 for
eight out of ten
that's what i would say
7.58 haven't seen earth's mighty stairs
i'm a big fan of the uh oh we got the
super chats i'm a big fan of the uh
uh spectacular spider-man though they
have a great black uh symbiote attached
i think it's so so well flushed out in
fact i'm hoping that for the next
installment after spider-man no way home
they do like some type of symbiote
attachment to peter parker because they
do something that's very personal for
him that's not all about setting up
venom like it's so good you know
i'm getting hungry
you can leave if you want you can go get
food and bring it to us you could go get
the donuts which which way are we going
on super chats up or down up we're
always going up we're on bntw news now
yeah happy birthday greg and who's the
better batman who laughs or superman
what what's the question better the
batman who laughs or superman i'm
interested in all three opinions let's
settle this
the batman who laughs yeah it's the like
really freaky looking one with the spike
strip around his eyes and the big nasty
teeth i'll just pull up an image i think
we're talking about which batman who
actually and i thought kevin conroy
who's batman is the best laughs i mean
kevin conroy has a very unsettling laugh
in the killing joke
i didn't watch that yeah he's got
various
he's done some other things where he's
laughing was it was it good though no
not really
uh where there's other ones where he's
like looks a little bit intoxicated but
or like he's under the you know he's
under the influence of something but
yeah pizza time yep gonna get gonna get
pizza for my birthday that's my favorite
thing to eat
i love pizza it's a prom though man i
just eat too much of it if it's if it's
there i'm going to eat it it's like i
always feel like i need more pizza can't
stop it's a real it's a real problem i
always feel like i need more pizza can't
stop addicted to the
pizza that's that's just for you so when
you reach the top of the super chest on
your end it said 3 800 that is not at
all wonderful that's not
the usual
i don't have like a goal with what to
hit here or something like that we will
go until we hit the number yeah we'll go
until we're at five thousand dollars
no i mean i just want to go to like 130
145
um it was really just about the time you
know three thousand four hundred dollars
i mean i'll tell you i'll tell you all
really yeah yeah we're like no we're not
there um happy okay so where are we at
happy birthday greg okay so yeah i would
say uh batman who laughs
uh i don't know i don't i really don't
have an answer for that i feel like jaby
doesn't know what we're talking about
i feel like superman would probably best
him in a fight but i for days and days
someone give me a little bit of
confidence more drawn to the batman who
laughs beyond the pictures like what
what how would we decide this
i mean
i gotta clarify on like what level i
don't think the batman who laughs has as
much the thing is like i don't think he
has as much like supernatural or like
you know otherworldly power as superman
but he is like maniacally evil it sounds
like this is john's answer i mean i just
i just
like character-wise i would go with the
batman who laughs just because i find
that more interesting and more crazy and
weird but i feel like superman would win
the fight if that's who's better in a
fight but who's more interesting like i
i think uh i would go with batman who
laughed they totally did do batman in a
steel suit
are you are you joking
a call back to a joke yes an hour 40
minutes ago because no
great to see you katrina she can't send
a text but she can uh she can go on a
live trina alicia yeah oh hello
she watched an indian film with me once
wow she's committed uh fireline
entertainment what's up alan
happy birthday brother hope you have an
incredible day on your special day with
family and friends i'm only seeing my
friends i have no interest in seeing my
family so what i've decided to do is
we're gonna go watch shang qi so i have
to talk with them
and then once the movie's done i'm gonna
go sorry guys got a jet
see ya
is that okay with you
oh you're talking to him i thought you
were talking about john the batman who
would i say i'm gonna hang out with my
family i'm talking about john
[Music]
i don't want to see john so we're just
going to sit in this theater and watch
chang-chi again
the batman who laughs is someone who is
batshit crazy yet is smart and
meticulous with his planning and can
[ __ ] anyone up according to gabriel
moronis okay the hybrid of batman and
also the joker i hope that's who robert
padden says definitely vote superman on
that one
oh yes
wow okay well thank you fireline
entertainment alan go subscribe to his
channel james crumsy happy birthday greg
december hurry up boba
boba i wish i could talk about it but i
know someone who worked on the show
and let's just say it's gonna be [ __ ]
awesome all right
boba this is a story about a store this
is a story about a cafe yeah i got
excited bubble tea
it sounds like i love some bubble tea
place comedy don't worry
chris fleming is doing the theme song
yeah it's uh book of boba fett and yeah
there's some pretty amazing things that
come out of it trust me on that all
right i can't wait to react to that i
indirectly sort of helped with the
lightsaber stuff in the last season
of the mandalorian yeah are you a
liberty to share it's super like low
rent in the way that i contributed
basically i was borrowing some i saw it
i was borrowing some
lightsabers i was wearing some like
lightsabers from uh friends that have
done lightsaber fights because i was
planning to make another one and a
friend of mine whose fiance i believe
was working on the show was like oh
you've got lightsabers can my fiance
borrow it so we he can use it for the
choreography for amanda lloyd i'm like
[ __ ] yeah that's awesome just do what
you want just get me a part in the show
she's like i'll try
she got herself she got herself a part
in the show
she didn't try i uh i wrote an episode
of the book of boba fett
dude that's so cool what was the episode
about tell us everything now uh it
deviates from the actual storyline they
didn't use it
right here it includes miles morales and
doctors
i was just trying to get creative damn
some people inside the box just saw two
people give some really high super chats
thank you guys whoa uh we will get there
i promise we're just going over we're
getting there let's skip everyone and go
i know thank you guys so much denise
geek
guys go watch the gallifrey gals um liv
uh denis alegic
can you guys please react to the posts i
tagged you on instagram about spiderman
at my home it's about a bunch of league
stuff about the movie we'll have to
check it out and if we can't feature
actual like photo leaks yeah because
they will come and how did you how did
you read the name dennis
okay or denis i read that as allergic
like magic
dennis allergic dude
yes
living freak
are you are you still answering the last
questions that was going on no okay yeah
let's check it out but yeah
i just want the mcu to establish the
spider-man clone saga and the onslaught
storyline i love the other stuff but i
needed this
i don't know the onslaught storyline
[ __ ] i feel bad whenever i don't know
something i'm like man how dare you
review
but the spiderman clone saga is one that
i they've been teasing that like a lot
of people are really championing for to
to get going we're already there
fire lines we're already entertaining
this tom holland is a clone happy
[ __ ] insane it's the big twist did
you hear about top gun too and mission
impossible 7 both being moved to 2022
middle
that sucks however it's still your b day
that's awesomey
the miz lol thanks alan i think top gun
i mean
look
if anyone has demonstrated they care
about the movie theater experience it's
[ __ ] tom cruise all right what if
they came out the same day as a double
feature i mean that almost happened with
the matrix and john wick four they
almost put them out on the same they had
the same release date
that would be amazing yeah kiana day you
would actually go to both but um i i
don't i personally wouldn't like that
however uh i i am totally for that
moving top gun two in mi7 because
tom cruise like
he he is one where he really has like
he's very outspoken about the theatrical
experience and he makes things like he
he gets the imax involved for all the
right reasons so it's like both top gun
2 and mi7 are deserved to be watched on
imac specifically because they get imax
cameras for them you cried during the
top gun trailer reaction i did yeah dude
embarrassing he doesn't cried anything
emotional
damn a freaking plane in the sky that
makes him go my god you cry for machines
that's a slow movie you really relate to
tech
that one there moved him to tears
julian t
say it happy birthday gregory boy sup
jabs hey john love all your channels he
donated he had 50 pounds you just just
skipped you just skipped
50 pounds i gotta shout that out that's
that's like double worth more than
dollars
double american money it's worth more
than our funny money over here
you know what they call the money in
canada
the loony the loony and that's a good uh
metaphor carl uh if you don't stop you
will have to get
blocked i'm sorry who's carl the guy who
keeps saying virus if you keep going you
will get blocked
uh saya diego how do you say that
diakite is my guess
happy birthday bro i appreciate your
existence i appreciate your existence
and your super chat i appreciate that
more than your existence in fact that
makes me appreciate your existence even
more
see it's like a cyclical thing dude a
cycle of appreciation cycle of
appreciation
and it moves us all omni media media one
of the best people i've ever gotten to
meet on this internet sphere omni media
go check out his youtube channel happy
birthday man shane she was
you said shang chi by the way i did yeah
i [ __ ] up
you
raised the thing i'm a hypocrite you're
a bad asian i'm a [ __ ] hypocrite
critical asian i basically heard ching
chong chi oh god
racist i am not yet sending any of this
shanxi was chef's
[Music]
complaining that i don't when we do our
live stream spoiler talk for shanghai we
gotta have a
pronunciation this graphic we'll just
have a graphic that says
chickadee china yeah
it's so racist zodiac mob happy birthday
greg thank you one of the best parts of
my day is whenever youtube actually
tells me you guys uploaded same with
jaby thanks for all your effort you put
into all of your content appreciate it
man
you're welcome we do it you're welcome
i mean yeah no i would say thank you for
the compliment but i think we earned
that
it's just i just expect people to say
that now so
yeah
we should move on
guys
zodiac mob thank you for your birthday
i'll bless you with that gift all your
likes thank you your thumbs will become
your own thumbs so your likes will be
eternal dude and you'll have a scary
trippy hand with a lot of thumbs
enjoy
evil dead kind of thing right yeah
absolutely or dr strange uh heroes
reforged we got loonies and toonies in
the live chat that is trading in the
currency that is true heroes reforged
happy birthday take that adsense thank
you heroes reports thank you buddy y'all
that's uh youtube will get three dollars
from that too thank you dude appreciate
it man
alto voltaire
ever had a birthday beat down
that just reminded me of something you
ever seen mario warfare on youtube
you got to do a reaction to that i think
people would love it i think your
audience would love it mario warfare is
a combination of modern warfare and
mario and it's
amazing can you ban uh carl oh yeah
let's do it
sorry guys if you span it's gonna it's
gonna
you're gonna it's what's gonna happen
it [ __ ] annoys me
as much as it i'm sure it annoys
more people in the chat so yeah i don't
feel a thing
uh i maybe one day jaby
maybe
yeah we're going to do a spoiler talk
for seong chi i'm going to make sure i'm
well well rested for that one wait a
minute you never gave me a birthday
beatdown
uh
i don't know i i i don't know what a
birthday beat down i did that when i
joined a crew once i got beat down yeah
something like the
usana the clips clips i think usana
mm-hmm the clips are or
the network marketing it was one of the
two it was either
it was either a multi-level marketing or
a gang i'm not sure which one
i should say yeah it was an mcn it was a
multi-channel network multi-channel
network
all right fireline entertainment hey
buddy good good to see you guys together
nice to you john anthony
i called you anthony miss seeing you all
in person hopefully soon we can go grab
a nice gold one cold stripper wait who
is this cole allen
stripper allen
allen no i'm thinking of the little uh
alan
was it a squirrel or a beaver allen
allen steve it's this is the t-rex it's
a doctor no you know what i'm talking
about no maybe but not right where the
animals are talking they voiced over all
the animals okay is this someone in the
chat knows what i'm talking about or is
this like the nut job oh i was a gopher
who popped out i was going ellen ellen
no
thank you dale appreciate it
no no no guys all i really care about is
you hit that like button
my favorite marvel villain is actually
uh not my favorite movie but my favorite
villain would have to be uh tony lung
someone please give clarification on the
thing i was just referencing the allen
joke the steve guys we got to get this
stephen allen animal thing settled so
whoever's got it there's a gopher or a
squirrel
what a great name
detective jim perry detective jim i'm on
the case
happy birthday greg question for all of
you guys you could cast an act in a row
in the mcu which actor and what role
i would say
i would love john humphrey is miles
morales john humphrey
as
you can see
to replace chadwick i am the logical
choice be like
hey guys i'm taking over wakanda
i'm very excited to keep watching this
that was a great impression of me they
know what i'm talking about but they
don't know the name of the video gophers
beaver disney fan says he understood the
reference secret life pets i would like
no it's not that it was a real real
animal's dubbed i would like to see uh
right uh eric voss as a uh variant of
deadpool is what i would like to see ooh
that's a good one no he said he would he
wanted to do captain america
no he didn't yes he did eric voss said
that yes when did he say that in one of
the videos i'm sure he said that i'm
like 100
sure he said that
[Laughter]
no he totally said he wanted to be a
variant of the when he was doing the
breakdowns for um
the variant show the tva stuff
loki
i want to hey we've been on this for
like two hours [ __ ] just starts falling
out of your head after a while how long
was your live stream before you showed
up two hours
i want
i was just hopping around live streams
that's what i'm saying i've been live
streaming all day so it's like after a
certain point you start saying dumb ass
[ __ ] that one has sunglasses on there's
just blister rings yeah there's bright
glowing red
i think he would be great somewhere in
the mcu i would love to see i want
jackie chan to play uh peter parker
uncle uncle oh
no
oh chucky happy born greg thanks buddy
them glasses we have one clark kent two
bruce lee's right whoo
i am bruce lee lana pico
five bucks oh and lana we got this thank
you so much green shots
of sweetheart we got the screen shot
from lana because she neglected to put
her well wish in the chat
drag it over there dragon drag that chat
over there what's going on here forgot
to include a message with my super chat
but happiest of birthday wishes to greg
so nice of your brother to do this so
soon after getting his eyes dilated oh
you're fantastic lana thank you so much
you're the best sounded a bit like bill
wurtz there for a second i that was
exactly my goal
so lana's been such a sweetheart to us
for so long she is not to me
i shall follow you you never know it
could change dakota jones
my instagram he's he's made this for oh
wait uh they're both upside down all
right just turn your phone over hey you
made this for us both of these
homelander and deathstroke i got it
thank you buddy beauties look at them oh
that's cool and homelander that's pretty
cool too that and it made this joker
funko pop that's nailed into the top
there
nailed down there so it doesn't fall on
the computer you read the chat back oh
yeah ab fab nips thank you guys so much
for being here hit that like button if
you haven't done so already nips too
good for you wanted to share my top 10
mcu movie thoughts we did you did on the
on the other one end game
guardians one chunk chief thor ragnarok
captain winner soldier thoughts so this
is a good it's a good ranking look guys
anyone in this live stream just gonna
let you know if you decide to um add a
story of me on instagram i will add it
to my timeline on on the story you
didn't do mine
uh i completely you're blocked
[Laughter]
that makes so much sense so the system
works
brian williams happy birthday greg i'm
with john though and it's gemini all day
take care fellas oh
fellow gemini thank you brian that i
know one person won't roll their eyes
and or hiss at me and that's you buddy
okay psych greg i was very tired when i
joined the stream haha
greg was very i was very tired when i
joined the stream that is me
that's my secret i'm always tired and
sometimes that works to my advantage
where i'm just like loose i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm so honest and then other times
i'm just like i'm so brain day guys i'm
sorry
i'm gone live yeah john's haha was the
most enthusiastic haha of all time
that's right man i'm good that was the
greatest haha of all time you belong at
the haha cafe shield vids happy birthday
greg just wanted to take this time to
say i love your aos reactions oh wait
that's john
love your shades oh that's your brother
love your dedication
love your dedication that i will not
credit at all for the actual content
it's everything else besides those two
very specific things i've never held any
infl i hate i've never held any
influence in the direction of this
channel before this is john's channel
this everyone remembers that
john has guided everything john's
channel and anything i've done has just
been jaby's ideas yeah whenever you want
to know that yeah greg is not in any way
the sort of engine that drives all of
that john came up with the first part of
the name of the channel
uh i was like we shouldn't just be like
floating out there we need to be
definitive
there could be other real rejects all
right
justin timberlake was like take out the
the and john was like [ __ ] you happy b
day greg big john fan here you got it
right it's a weird thing to hear but i
really appreciate it that's a deep
reference right surreal say it again no
explain it to me explain the joke
justin timberlake
uh look i think hugh jackman could make
a cameo in deadpool 3 but it's not going
to happen
you never saw the social network i did
it's just been a hot minute yes
the real john jacks that we should
change the channel to that
that's going to
make people uh john is the real reason
confused
i mean kind of
oh no look guys
seriously
john
what
it's about time i hand over all the
reins to you no it is not i'm gonna help
your sketches are freaking hilarious i
mean those are all john
[Laughter]
they are do it john i can come up with a
i i have the
frustratingly great ability to be like i
just came up with the whole idea and i
just wrote it out in like 40 in like 20
minutes like i i so envy that ability
yeah well you shouldn't because john's
envious of himself is what he should
tell you guys right now that's right i'm
envious of my own just like overly
flowing font of creative ideas
alex salinas happy birthday greg hope
your day is amazing also hope john and
jaby are having a good day too i'm
working on this this is exciting love
all you guys
[Laughter]
thank you alex
time to hand john the shield so he can
have his sam wilson art hobby chicks is
jeb
i mean i would love to commit ten
episodes of john learning to
feel like he's worthy of holding up the
mantle of the real riches that would be
a character a self-indulgent thing and
we run out of ideas by episode one
happy birthday thank
you it took me years to grow up my hair
uh hybrid in the chat zodiac mob i think
i win i share a birthday with zendaya my
god you lucky son of a [ __ ] did anybody
see the zendaya and john david
washington film now i hear they're
complaining a lot
there's a long argument that movie like
like revolutionary road the shark move a
shark movie deep blue water or something
like that there it was i forgot the name
of it it was like
no it was an indie film with a married
couple that gets lost at sea and they
get eaten by sharks blue valentine open
water open water there you go that's the
one indian film no it's american indie
film indy
zendaya and john david washington are
not in open water no i'm saying open
water was a a married couple arguing the
entire movie so i'm saying it's kind of
like that except they're in a house yeah
no sharks so ones accept each other
i think it's better with the shark
with a shark walking around yeah this is
in the background of the house anthony
ochoas is to make sure to see shanghai
and candyman in theaters leave your
thoughts in the chat if you saw candyman
what did you think tm
happy birthday jared or whatever your
name is that i don't [ __ ] know
anymore it's josh get it right
little [ __ ] guzzler jesus christ said
nothing you don't need to oh wait was
the name
goodness what the hell
random
happy birthday greg my question do you
think that we'll see toby and andrew in
the next no way home trailer i think
we'll get a tease of them but i don't
think we'll see them i think you'll see
like the suit
or you might hear a voice or you might
just hear toby say
with great power
comes and it'll be interrupted by a joke
[Laughter]
did you guys know ed asner
played jay jonah jameson in the 90s
animated series yes
and he played uncle ben in the
spectacular spider-man there's also
hudson in the gargoyles cartoon show yes
but she means spider-man related
but all right disney though crossover
fair enough still disney fair enough
crashing coyote in the chat points out
kevin feige produced the raimi trilogy
and a lot of people seem to forget that
i didn't even know that well he wasn't
head producer he was like one of like
the
secondary was involved in it for sure do
you think people will be happy or upset
if toby mcguire does a dance like he did
in spider-man so happy i think that's
how he should enter that's the one they
should pluck out of the universe he just
goes
[Laughter]
i just want someone to
tell about the multiverse problem and i
just wanted to say i missed the part
where that's mine
he's just full on like
spider-man one though
no no he should just be a compendium of
classic quotes but with an air of i
don't care what's going on yeah
gino the pill happy birthday greg jaby
and john
i read that
it's all our birthdays today thank you
thank you kendall biard happy birthday
greg thank you so much kendall oh so
nice lovely emojis
to have like a 95
analytics used to say it was a 95
um
uh male demographic five percent female
demographic and now we're at 85 15 and i
believe that 15 percent has showed up in
our live stream today so thank you
ladies
what is yours
all that sex appeal you have wanna know
enjoy your birthday and thank you for
such great content over the past year
you're welcome i cannot enjoy my
birthday because if i have to step away
from filming or editing i don't feel
complete
that's why i'm live streaming the amount
of people who are like let me take you
out to lunch i said no
no no i'm going live only if i get i
don't live stream it i don't socialize
in the afternoon hours you guys wanna
you guys wanna hang out with me no no no
i'm hanging out with the people who see
me every day that's you guys
yeah man the people are always there
people who are just there for your
birthday yeah it's [ __ ] like
that would make an excuse thanks tm
thanks for being here tiny tempest oh
happy birthday 15
i see you had a haircut as well it was
my birthday yesterday it's the former
master bee by the way hope you guys are
well master b master b i i recognize
yeah that sexy profile pic good to see
you buddy monochrome thanks for being
here man called jerusalem gave you a
cake oh dude super stick
that's a beautiful little pink cake too
i want to eat it
uh clarence
coltart happy birthday gwen gweig
wow i don't think i've ever ever really
pretty much
wow once again so racist
happy birthday greg
the question i have for you three is
which marvel character isn't as well
known would you like to see the mco
well i would love to see um
a jaby take this answer first is what i
would love
to i was just thinking about you as a
little baby the question i have for you
there is which marvel character that
isn't well known would you like to see
in the mcu
take it away jaby i don't i don't know
you're in the spider-man chair
take it away john take it
away my man spider movie okay i know
that's a character creative for the
cartoons but that's what i want and
that's what i don't expect to get still
peter parker though
uh
didn't he project just the arms yeah the
arms come out they come out of him yeah
still peter monstrosity so you want
peter parker to go down that fly path
yes i would love a properly sized
wolverine in the mcu i want the the fu
man shoe
i want them to do a comic's accurate
depiction of the mandarin yeah what is
there a problem come on guys
wolverine is supposed to be like 5'3 and
they made him six foot two it's hard to
find five three actors out there who are
built like celebrate [ __ ] houses oh it's
hard um danny devito wolverine perfect
casting god who would be a marvel
character i would love to see they're
already doing craven
um
craven i really enjoyed there was this
character
they were doing like everyone already
that i know hold on there was this time
traveling character there was a time
traveling character in x-men the fox
animated series
who he was like a black dude with i
think he had a scar on his face and long
curly hair
you know i'm talking about did you watch
the cartoon
he's like my power is absorbing powers
and wolverine's like absorb these and he
had the
no
character
i would love to bring
morph
from x-men into it he's just like a male
mystique but i would love to see more
gambit squirrel girl they brought gamut
alive before squirrel girl let's do that
but squirrel girls
faith gettys
agrees with me bishop
bishop we got a really high [ __ ]
bishop is in uh days of future past but
not on the mcu yeah but he was white
wasn't it and accurate cyclops would be
great you got to bring bishop white or
black in the movie i can't remember it's
black
okay then they did my thing
absorbing man
somebody's getting a really high super
chat thank you yeah nightcrawler i think
the sodium movies will eventually become
more mcu apparent soon
what i want them to do is bring from the
dc world i want them to bring scarface
into it do you guys know scarface
do you guys know scarface
not as well as clay face he's got a
puppy he's like uh ventriloquist all
right okay all right yeah i've seen that
guy i think he'd be hilarious gabrielle
moroney's happy birthday greg by the way
what would scare you more a laughing
batman or a silent spider-man
i think um a silent spider-man he like
there's okay why i keep going back to
this but why would that scary more than
a laughing batman how is he laughing
like
he's going out
[Laughter]
that would be scary but if he's just
like chuckling i would be like oh good
for him he needs some joy in his life
i think uh
i mean when someone's silent you have no
idea what they're thinking or feeling
and he's fully masked like batman you
could even see his mouth
whereas uh spider there was this great
episode in spectacular spider-man where
he is like actually
battling the sinister six and he's not
talking the whole time like he's just
completely silent for reasons i won't
give away
but uh
it is it is intimidating and like
spider-man as i seem like incredibly
badass because and they are like saying
like why aren't you quitting like
they're saying all this [ __ ] they're
like why are you being yourself and it
makes him that much more intense when he
isn't uh talking actually i think he'd
be really intimidating going back to the
previous question what about jubilee
we've barely seen her in the movies who
jubilee jubilee yeah that'd be great
yeah that'd be great yeah just uh but
thank you gabriel all right guys we
gotta start speed right cause we gotta
start filming some [ __ ] yeah justin i
cannot read russian absolute points
exist to differentiate one universe from
another if two universes had the same
absolute points they would be the same
invariant
jabby talking about hentai is an
absolute point
that
that was great that was i'm going to
school you guys
and then make a really good call back
here yeah that was really well done
thank you buddy
happy birthday beer did you check the
vaught international channel it's pretty
funny all the news about the seven
before the new season of the no i
haven't heard any of that [ __ ] yet no i
have to check it out thank you for the
heads up calderocian that's exciting
i'll take that one too a jeep hi happy
birthday greg best memory with jaby
during your birthday maybe you can say
best or worst oh
god
what's the worst uh jaby tell a story
from my birthday
oh god
i don't know i don't pay attention to
your birthday i don't do that this is
the most i've ever spent time with you
on your birthday it is
honestly most consecutive hours probably
i can't remember any of greg's birthdays
that's weird
i can remember i can remember the day i
the first day i saw you
all right what was that that was the
best birthday tell that story the first
time you saw me tell it to the audience
um and so what happened was like my mom
was in the hospital because she had a
c-section because greg
wanted to get himself choked out being
stubborn
he wanted to get himself choked out the
umbilical cord wrapped around his neck
and so they had to do an emergency
c-section thing get him out of my mom's
stomach as fast as possible and when i
showed up to the hospital my mom looked
like she had been through battle
she was just like all messed up in the
bed and i looked down and greg was
asleep on his chest
oh
that's a good day no alcohol required no
alcohol required we probably shouldn't
have anything he became a real [ __ ]
after that
eddie eddie eddie eddie
happy birthday where would you break
shrink cheese powers level between all
the marvel characters
oh god what a [ __ ] complicated ass
question he's not really all that
powerful right 12.
what what are you number 12 he would be
12th on the roster
easy easy answer don't even need to
think about it 12 he's easily above of
hot guy and black widow
he's but yeah i mean out of all the ones
who don't really have super powers he's
kind of like more heightened than just
realistic fighter especially if he got
the rings yeah but i would say uh i'd
say he's like in the uh
i don't know yeah let's go 12. he's not
quite street level he's just a bit above
that but he's also not like god mode
yeah definitely in the top 432 jaby is
15 years older than me for everyone
asking
15 year age gap
gabriel morones also i'm seeing chongqi
tonight so i'm pumped for that i can
always count on you all to hype me up
for stuff or at the very least be hype
with me i feel like i set very realistic
expectations yeah absolutely pretty
honest go in ready to hate it and then
you'll love it
really that's the key to all movies is
expect everything to be abysmal and you
will be so surprised every time kate's
saying happy birty day get drunk in
stone i am neither right now
i wish i was one of them
living freak greg would you ever host a
live stream with the folks from
previewed they seem like a fun group why
the [ __ ] not
that'd be fun it's time because no
all right guys we got more stuff to film
in a second so
john let's refresh this page in this
stream wait hold on joseph boris didn't
get ready yes rejoice abortion we're
gonna fresh this see how much more we
have left then we'll cap it off soon
scarlett johansson from miles guys quit
overlooking the obvious happy birthday
greg
it's really time scarlett johansson's
proven she can play any ethnicity aren't
scarlett johansson and chris evans doing
some movie together right now yes it's
dealing with lawsuits yeah
he has a legal thriller there's a legal
thriller it's called marriage story too
marriage she's getting divorced again
that that ending oh we can't talk about
it right we can't spoil
the story
i want to do breakdowns of films like no
one gives a [ __ ] like that zendaya uh uh
washington movie we were just talking
about what the hell is that called
i wanted the first pen don't remember i
don't remember and uh and i want to call
it just mercy that's the michael b
jordan movie i want to do one for like
three billboards outside of episode
if you look in the background you can
see another billboard
i really wanted to do that i think
that'd be so funny
all right john close this out really
quick for it refresh this this club is
forum all right guys uh we're going to
refresh we'll see how much more we have
left but we are no longer going to be
accepting super chat so john do that
thing that we can turn
that back
on the breakfast club
that'd be fun you know what i'm saying
what i'm saying adam driver is great at
mirror story i like marriage story quite
a lot i'm not gonna lie i thought that
was amazing that ending
the ending hurt me
i thought it ended perfectly
yeah
i don't want to get into it we are
actually brothers okay so i'm definitely
most days yeah just that this is stupid
shits no
turn off the super chat we're not like
my brother i guess my job is down here i
can leave my brother's just always like
it's like we're going to keep going as
long as you don't know we got we got
stuff to film yeah because super what we
learned last time that's how you super
chats will keep on that's how you end up
in a 12 and a half hour live stream and
refresh that john is i believe what what
is you'd like to come come
to the future of the show how do you
think the scenario you would want to
play out i would like to see the dark
doctor strange come to the live action i
feel like that'd be very very engaging
to say the least
what's going on we're just refreshing
we're just refreshing [ __ ]
we're just refreshing all right that's
why they thought you got four thousand
dollars because there's a number at the
top of this that says four grand has
nothing to do with the live stream
no
oh that right maybe that's all time
since he was a baby that's that's over
the course of since we got a stream laps
all right which might sound very
disappointing to a lot of you guys i
need a stream i mean people don't use
the streamlabs link anywhere near as
much as the super chat it's all it's all
very money out to anus well let's pull
it up hey greg happy birthday
podna thanks to you and john for having
an awesome channel and have a beer
and a comic book both on me have a beer
or a comic book money out the anus he
just shot that ten dollars out of his
dancing i really appreciate that money
out the anus would you if you had that
if you pooped money how would you feel
how would you use it
you you'd what are the costs it would be
a waste
it would be a waste not to use it what
if i mean [ __ ] money but it still
smelled like [ __ ] does that ever happen
to you is that ever uh roger's dilemma
in american dad does he ever have that
dilemma i didn't get far enough into
family guy not a family guy uh american
dad i don't know it sounds like a thing
seth mcfarlane would come up to yeah do
you know what i'm talking about roger
roger like poops out diamonds or
something
oh yeah oh yeah they they had an
overarching storyline they took so
serious yeah that was great does it ever
come back as a yeah
they bring it back so like monetary
exchange ever i don't i don't know like
it just keeps enhancing the plot they
treat it like the ring from lord of the
rings it's brilliant
brilliant plot
um
hey
jaby when you left the live stream 100
people left real rejects
just so you know what if brie larson
like a white reporter that would be a
funny ass
filipino
chris 15. happy birthday with the rumors
of the netflix marvel characters
appearing in the mcu which characters
you think or want to appear in the mcu
oh easy iron fist
davos
oh what's her name jessica hedwig
jessica jones's friend what's her name
oh trish yeah trish walker trish walker
absolutely i want all them and then i
just want them to just get shot yeah
except for jessica hemwick she deserves
another [ __ ] okay but then we keep luke
cage we keep mariah we keep uh
charlie cox
karen why not
i just want like 10 of cottonmouth
would be great yeah that'd be amazing
uh yeah i think i i think for sure
daredevil i would like i would like the
defenders to stick around and john
bernthal i've never seen a picture of
iron fist that man recast danny ran a
picture of iron fist yeah have you ever
what do you mean a picture anytime any
time we've seen an image of iron fist
i'm just sad this is like you should see
the pictures move
i'm talking about like in breakdowns and
stuff like that
danny ran
i
there are compilations online i need to
control my emotions
oh my god
why aren't you speaking loudly
why are you holding everything in
i have to do an american flag
to bring it back to the theme of the
stream jaby can you tell us
he tells us a story about greg growing
up and john i don't intentionally leave
you out we have many interactions on the
psych reactions can't wait to see the
reaction to the next episode oh thanks
buddy are you okay with the story that
we talked about the last time we all had
to get together
no i'm ashamed of my past as a
six-year-old boy are you okay with that
yeah yeah you're okay with that okay all
right so uh this is a two-part story
we'll tell the first part then we'll
tell the second part later so uh when
greg and i were growing up my dad for
whatever reason decided to put our
family computer in the kitchen
right that's so that's where i'd be late
nights on aol instant messenger and one
evening greg walks in
five or six years old
hentai wasn't around back then
craig walked in
greg walked in it was we had lime wire
greg walked in and he there's we had a
garbage bag we didn't have a proper
garbage pail it was just a bag that my
parents would use from like target
makeshift garbage and he pulled his
pants down
and i'm like greg what the hell are you
doing and he's his pants he just he just
looks at me scratching himself just
looks at me like annoyed scratching
himself and then he proceeds to urinate
into the garbage bag i'm like what are
you doing greg it's all true it's a
classic and then he pulls his pants back
up and goes back to sleep and i tried
telling my parents i'm like greg peed in
the garbage and they wouldn't believe me
that's the end of part one what do they
think in the garbage you will tell part
two at the end of the stream what did
what did they think peed in the garbage
they didn't think anything peed in the
garbage they just didn't believe they
didn't smell the garbage nothing peed in
the garbage
all right
artist dylan we got some limewire love
in the main chat can you scroll up no
porn in the kitchen honest dylan hey
y'all been watching since 2014 i wanted
to say happy birthday hope to see you
someday you've met my friends from the
artist of the uh anyways what's your
thought of cobra kai so far oh the cobra
is great
and as it was also in cobra kai he was
johnny lawrence's father yes
uh yeah i'm very excited for cobra kai
season four
makes me feel like i gotta go back and
re-watch the [ __ ] kids
i watched three when season three was
airing and now i'm like no i gotta
re-watch that that's the problem is like
oh man i gotta i gotta watch a movie i
don't really care for yeah just to be
refreshed on it and you should watch
them
yeah
and now they got season five green list
if they can end it with hillary swink
that would be epic that would be legit
that would be super epic was she was she
the next karate kid yeah it's gotta
happen for some reason for the longest
time i thought it was the lady from
mortal kombat as as the next karate kid
i don't know why i thought that which
bridgette
nelson or something nielsen yeah yeah
the one who snaps kano's neck she played
sonia blade yeah bridge
the one with the boobs
yeah bridgette why do women have boobs
the one with the boobs
you don't remember that as a kid like
that just like
set off all kinds of alarms of
awesomeness so like when she like goes
onto her hands and wraps her legs around
kano's neck
you know what i'm saying yeah and then
shang tsung looks very corny
yeah kinky because she's about to pop
out it's actually
blitz games that's not what said
you can't run from me
blitz games in the chats of the six
sinister six member is bob chapeck oh
yeah i think that's the case flav what
are you saying many things to look
forward to
for for me this year many of my favs fab
shows return eternals top gun no way
home top gun's been moved no way home
patreon reactions avatar finale that's
right two episodes away psych episode
three finale season three finale many
other reactions from you guys
jaby hope your eyes heal love you john
happy birthday getting great take care
that that comment looked like it took a
lot of work thank you
thank you phil i love you buddy hector
the sector you're the besticals happy
birthday brother
never a day when i don't why is it like
that never a day when i don't smile for
your content doesn't sound like that
happy birthday
happy happy
reference
it's no good i can't do it oh yeah
all right
you got show omni media did i tell you
that i i watched the x-men movie their
first x-men movie with david hayder in
the room
it was pretty awesome and the scene
where um storm says you know what
happens to a toad that gets struck by
lightning the same thing that happens to
everything else
he said i didn't write that [ __ ] line
halle berry improvised
no it was it was um what's his name uh
um who did the avengers i can't remember
his name awesome josh we didn't wrote
that line
joss whedon wrote that line but it came
out
he's good at the clever lines but that
just came out horrible i didn't know how
to direct it no i got a note from us one
of the producers on did you read this
one
yeah we made that public yeah yeah
barney teenager paused that fk moment a
lot
i got a note from one of the producers
on one of the scripts i'm working on
that i just loved recently the note was
i like it's a horror script i like the
character development but i'd rather
sacrifice it to get to the action faster
and i was like
what
[Laughter]
have you not read every bad horror movie
review ever now i'm gonna have to
promote this movie when it comes out
is that it's not the one i talked about
on the uh that i talked about a few
months ago it's a different one um
anyway
hi happy birthday long time ago i came
across your channel when you were known
as ryan wright and i came right and i
came across jaby's channel and it took a
long time when i realized you both are
brothers by the way i'm also known as
potato stuff oh potato stuff going on
buddy
yeah man dude a lot of people don't
realize you and i are brothers and i'm
like quote clearly i only figured it out
yesterday clearly we're brothers they
look exactly the same i don't buy it i
think we look exactly the same i think i
like i'm a little bit nicer it's a
marketing ploy you're nicer than me this
is nicer than me just like how he says
that
you think you're nicer than me nicer
[ __ ] i'm the nicest person i've ever
met i'm so [ __ ] humble
hands down on the humble list
riley peter i think greg should do these
last two ones because
happy birthday greg i may not
participate in the patreon discord
server
but
i always stay up to date on your videos
and you guys are killing it sometimes i
touch myself to you at night and
occasionally i think what am i doing
with my life i was like gotta find other
youtubers
keep up the great work you freaking
nerds
thank you riley that's such a generous
super chat damn i've never i've never
felt so honored and touched in my life
thank you buddy
that's really kind to you you gotta read
the next one slowly ramon guerrero
guerrero
the gun but we are close we're actually
thank you for the sticker dude what is
it
is it like a little thing it's a samurai
those are my favorite kind of super
chats when i don't have to really read
anything it's a samurai it's a little
samurai creature
it's a samurai with fireworks
all right
now julian t
happy b day gregory boy sup jabby hey
john love all your channels thank you
julian t for being here man oh thank you
thank you for that very generous i think
john's got this next one oh
mr eco black
happy b day greg i turned 35 today
happy birthday to you brother robin hey
you're that man hey so much older than
you were when you were a child
dude every moment that is true
did you like use all the jokes on your
live stream today
thank you
rob a eric horstner horstmann my man
he's got a real rejects he has a big
real reason he's really
a very real permanent real rejection
that in no way was a mistake god just a
quick happy birthday wish why quick
because you're doing the stream on a
freaking workday that's why bye no oh
eric still i'm just happy you popped in
here really quick tony tedford with a
whopping 100
happy birthday this is for stopping and
taking that pic with me at sdcc in 2019
oh dude i remember that
you remember that because it was the
only time that it happened the only time
anyone's ever actually asked me for a
photo in person
but thank you tony that's such a
generous super chat oh thank you i'm
gonna use that hundred dollars and give
it to me
thank you yeah that's absolutely well
after after youtube takes us ninety
percent cut all the proceeds after
funding youtube goes to greg happy
birthday greg who went into dance with
tony that's really generous chase
gardner
that's that's why that's the highest one
who went into dance off chris pratt
starlord versus tony mcguire peter
parker oh toby mcguire dance off that
one had way more of a cultural impact
yeah absolutely i mean toby you know he
clearly appreciates you know like jazz
and other kinds of music so there oh
thank you so much hannah paige i love
you guys channel so much and happy b day
craig love all the emojis you just used
thank you poeven meyer oh oh it's the
last one oh greg can read that one then
i shared a birthday with eminem that's
[ __ ] awesome man i mean it was my
favorite
worst day for a birthday
because you'll never be the goat you'll
never be the goat hey you got to
celebrate
masturbate while i celebrate
my special date
uh all right cool well thank you guys
let's go through let's do a speed round
of just a little regular live chat here
let's go eat
around
jaby is older get some food john perez
thank you so much
sorry i missed the beginning i was at
the cinemas watching chongqi honestly
phenomenal i'd love to agree with you
about the mandarin greg awesome thanks
for stopping by rosie so wait you didn't
like the mandarin yeah i said i hated it
the mandarins in that movie oh oh that's
right okay gotcha
[Music]
i hope he does the same song but just
with carnage
all right guys come on
for all you people who who miss when we
actually read the comments here and then
say we don't read them web warrior
nation if you can read this you are
awesome that's right we are people it's
games to be fair you do not need to have
a high iq to understand the emo peter
dance no you do
absolutely you're a little wrong about
that
happy birthday gotta dig deep for what
that's really all about what's going on
there ruben zafir y'all tripping i
appreciate
you know i've only gotten
i've only gotten uh
10 text messages about my birthday
oh i believe that only 10. usually i'm
i'm i'm overwhelmed but not ten people
big mo logan i am pescatarian actually
i'm i'm pescatarian these two are meat
eaters they kill animals that's right
how could they fix the birds of prey
after that
text message i thought birds of prey was
awesome are you texting me saying happy
birthday my brother just said happy
birthday to me thank you 11.
my favorite ice cream flavor i love a
good vegan like double chocolate
look out now
i go i go all hannibal electra on that
[ __ ]
i like a good coffee flavored ice cream
but truly it's just anything i can put
sprinkles in sixth member is ron
burgundy virgo seasoned nicole
put your number in the chat so we can
text you you know if anyone wants to do
instagram story i will add it in there
baca tara says i want neil degrasse
tyson to break down greg's birthday to
specific details details that lead to
his epicness of the human being that we
see today dude that would be amazing
specific details do you know who neil
degrasse tyson is oh my god yeah he
kneeled dad asked did i tell you i met
him oh really a long time ago he walked
past you too
i took a photo with him you remember
when i cut my finger open and i saw my
bone
uh
i think so yes yes it was wrapped up i
took a picture with degrasse tyson
holding up my stitched finger oh
cause of science
yeah sure does anyone want to hear the
rest of that story about greg yeah all
right we can't end the story without
going through the oh wait we got a
couple of streamlabs we gotta
sorry we got one more we gotta finish
off also john mark in the chat mark john
i think the daily bugle office style
show is a tremendous idea you should
pitch i think all you guys being here
does count as texting for happy b day
that's why we did the live stream
because i was like fine
out of the 100 people i know
only 10 yeah i'm only averaging 10
percent percent of your friends 10
percent of my friends that do it you
only got ten percent of actual friends
so i need to get
these everyone here to come here and say
people have until midnight okay
it's still the day off so yeah be when
you left the livestream 100 people left
with you wow what gives dude it's like a
char i can't hold down the fork i'm just
that cool that's funny when i leave live
streams it's just john the the view
account goes up
yeah and i don't even speak that's
because that's because that's because
youtube is racist let's see
youtube
all right and then lairdo wow thank you
buddy goodness lairdo oh we get more of
the percentage on that
you actually get happy birthday
i love you guys thank you lairdo can you
look at what lairdo means yeah absolute
vodka is that a star wars character it's
lando
isn't that a doctor strange character
what does alerto mean
i'm looking it up i believe we're doing
this on the live stream
yeah you've got better dexterity than i
do right there though is not an actual
word
the noble spanish surname laredo
descendant of lair
but yeah all right i try to do something
special i don't know what to do with
that yeah they're kind of like laredo
though so
we've been brothers for like 10 years
it's been a good run when you guys
decided today brothers i think it was a
really good idea because you guys oh we
revisit this we got to ask dollins we
gotta thank you guys so much for all the
contributions today thank you uh
sincerely like
wow a little tired today
i wonder where that's okay okay you'll
catch some z's when you edit it you've
been you've been taking it easy the last
several months with work greg has not
been up all night working non-stop when
you spend seven hours editing a
half-hour video that just keeps getting
blocked and you're like why are all my
friends videos not getting blocked by
mine
then you start feeling like i don't i
actually was texting people going i'm
not gonna put it up that what-if episode
i have not ever ever experienced that
ever never never not once for no videos
of mine
never never but never but i have figured
out that oval thing because like even on
the wheel of time trailer reaction today
like the
i was texting people like did yours get
blocked because if you or a copyright
claim because if it did i'm not going to
do it everyone's like no
everyone i talked to said no no to which
one wheel of time trailer for amazon the
second i upload
copyright claim and i was like are you
lying to me wendy lisa's
like are you live did your netflix one
get claims uh no support is yours yes i
didn't monetize that at all it was it
was claimed right
god damn it i was surprised like that i
mean my my but what i did was i saw
tyrone's wasn't quite wasn't was on his
channel so i'm like ty rhodes must have
not gotten claimed so i guess i'm gonna
keep it here yeah
um but i did that i did the oval thing
for the
uh for the amazon one that seemed to pan
out well anyway um autist dylan is
saying greg jaby and john are hanging on
a cliff you only have strength to pull
up one or you can walk away and eat
pizza what do you choose
[Laughter]
pizza
clearly if i if i need nutrition i have
the strength to pull myself if my my
if my emotions are not strong enough
because i'm that malnourished from not
having food in my body there's no point
man i'm probably going to take one i'm
probably going to fall over trying to
pick one up
one this way you don't you don't need to
make a sophie's choice you can yeah just
choose the ultimate like we all probably
value pizza more than you know either
one of us so
happy happy birthday
sophie is
all over this all right guys
look
where else do we got here let's do one
more great one and then
finish
thoughts on dune i just read a review
this morning um heavy spoilers has a new
video dad jokes galore what is it uh oh
remember when greg was on wizards of
waverly place
i was not on wizards away really playing
well big mo logan remembers it
i was doing background on that's so
raven
a long time ago
and uh um david henry was on there as a
guest star oh lexie j hello really i'd
say yeah yeah he came up to me anthony
anthony i know you you're greg's brother
i had no idea who david henry was at the
time
oh that's nice lexi jade says y'all feel
like a safe space to need uh to save
space i need uh without having to
actually make friends as an adult so
thank you oh that's really sweet well
come hang out with us
nima bethea's asking if we get an
awesome b day gift you're a little late
uh
you don't have to profane enthusiasm
john got me this tire got it
right
your new car gets all three different
sized tires said you got a new car so
here's a new tire for your car
and he said when i need to be
incognito you this tire right here right
that's your little donut in case you go
to flat he said i have to buy the extra
ones no they're back rollers shane she
is on greg's work [ __ ] no i'm doing it
too i'm a hypocrite
dude um all right cool so
so jo so all right
uh jaby finish off this live stream with
the rest of that story so what happened
was uh greg used to sleep on the couch
in the living room of our house because
my dad for whatever reason put a bunch
of junk on craig's bed on our bunk bed
and so that's where you would sleep and
my dad was like taking a nap on the
floor he laid out a blanket so he could
sleep watching tv
what happened
what's that i don't know someone's
saying your mic came undone is mike
working can we hear jaby kawaii
confirm it
no you're on this one though
now it's just a flat bar
you messed up your mic when you hit the
table jabs
talking to this one talk into that one
and i'll see what's wrong with this one
okay
this is not awkward uh so what happened
was greg was sleeping on the couch my
dad was taking a nap he fell asleep on
the room floor watching some show
and uh
while
my dad was sleeping greg woke up
and stood over my dad's head
pulled his pants down and proceeded to
pee onto the couch
and my dad woke up to that and started
screaming and greg woke up because he
was sleep peeing to the screaming of my
dad and they had to take the cushions
out and everything
they didn't buy a new couch they just
cleaned it up
that was the peace story greg didn't you
know he was a sleepwalking peer asleep
here i woke up
thinking about a dream of me doing that
that i saw in third person pov and what
i saw was my dad picking up stuff
looking really mad at me as if i did
this intentionally
that wasn't the case he never
sleepwalked p after that though yeah no
i think the trauma scared the pee out of
you on that man that was terrifying dad
mad dad mad dad
yeah on hbo
to be fair i think any dad would get
pretty mad about any damage
[Laughter]
all right sleep pier yeah no it's not a
crappy gift it's a great gift it's a
it's a tire
it's a couple of different sized tires
it's a tire set for a wonky car all
right guys we are at two and how long
have we been it also doubles as a chair
two hours 38 minutes and 12 13. 14
seconds it's time to end the stream
i appreciate you guys being here we're
going to shoot a video to put up for
tomorrow
which greg said i could be in
i know
we're gonna we gotta be efficient
if we do it that way
we gotta get things going
but thank you
you guys are amazing um you guys have
made uh this birthday a lot more
enjoyable if someone who's been very
sleep-deprived this week i i'm very
grateful for everyone who showed up here
anthony jabi kuwait thank you for being
here and telling my pissing on people's
story you're welcome john thank you for
my new bicycle anytime um oh but all you
guys i hope you guys enjoyed the stream
and i promise monday is going to be a
lot more energetic and sharp
we are going to kick ass take names
and you know [ __ ] on people we're going
to have a great time plenty of alcohol
required we're going to start off the
week monday get hungover to affect our
performance for the rest of the week oh
yeah be tired every other day be tired
every day of the week from [ __ ] up
our monday and before anyone else says
it happy birthday
yeah i'm glad you got that in there
and um i want to say thank you to
everyone especially who did contribute
to our super chats and our stream labs
so thank you guys so much
see you guys later yeah much love
sincerely peace out and um yeah
john
and the stream we are ending the stream
now goodbye love you goodbye
goodbye